Let's talk groceries, specifically your groceries with Instacart. You want your groceries just the way you like them, right? Well, the Instacart app lets you do just that. They have a new preference picker that lets you pick how ripe or unripe you want your bananas. Shoppers can see your preferences up front, helping guide their choices. Instacart, get groceries just how you like. Hello and welcome to your second drink of Weight Loss, Part 1. Well, I was going through our mail for this episode, and we had three families.
来聊聊杂货，特别是你通过 Instacart 购买的杂货。你想要买到称心如意的杂货，对吧？Instacart 应用程序就能满足你的需求。他们有一个新的偏好选择器，让你能挑选香蕉的成熟度。购物者可以提前看到你的偏好，从而引导他们的选择。Instacart，买到你心仪的杂货。你好，欢迎收听《减肥》第一部分，这是你的第二杯“减肥”特饮。我在为这一集整理邮件时，收到了三封来自家庭的来信。
male flurries on this episode. First, you know, Angela, how there are some episodes that people skip when they do a rewatch of the office? Oh, yeah, like Scott's Tots. Exactly. Well, I found out some people skip weight loss. Oh. They find this episode triggering. Just the whole idea of a weight loss competition and especially the dramatic measures that Kelly is taking, they can't watch it. They have to skip it. I mean, I do get that. And also, I don't think most companies are making their employees in a weight loss competition these days. Like, who's doing that? No, we've definitely evolved since this episode aired in, like, what, 2008? Well, we also got a lot of mail. Our second fan Mal Flurry was just people thanking you, Angela and Kelly Cantley,
这一集里有很多关于“粉丝来信”的内容。首先，安吉拉，你知道人们在重温《办公室》时会跳过某些剧集吗？哦，是的，比如《斯科特的托特们》。没错。我发现有些人会跳过《减肥》这一集。哦。他们觉得这一集会引发不适。整个减肥比赛的概念，尤其是凯利采取的极端措施，让他们看不下去。他们不得不跳过。我是说，我确实理解。而且，我觉得现在大多数公司都不会强迫员工参加减肥比赛。谁会这么做呢？不，自从这一集在 2008 年左右播出以来，我们肯定已经进步了。好吧，我们还收到了很多邮件。我们的第二个粉丝来信是感谢你，安吉拉和凯利·坎特利，
for explaining why Meredith's face is all red in this episode. Oh, yeah. You know, those are some of my favorite moments on this podcast when we can solve little lingering questions for people. I love it now, and we've talked about this before, where we meet people and they love the podcast, but they say thank you because now we know your crew. And we know what people do, what their jobs are, and they know Kelly Cantley. In her letter, she said thank you to Angela and Kelly Cantley. I love that. Well, finally, this was our first episode back in person doing the podcast after the pandemic. Oh my gosh. That's a big day.
感谢你们解释了为什么这一集中梅雷迪思的脸那么红。哦，是的。你知道，当我们在播客中为人们解决一些悬而未决的小问题时，那是我最喜欢的时刻之一。我现在很喜欢这样，我们之前也谈过，我们见到粉丝时，他们很喜欢这个播客，但他们会说谢谢，因为现在我们了解了你们的剧组。我们知道人们在做什么，他们的工作是什么，他们也认识凯利·坎特利。在她的信中，她向安吉拉和凯利·坎特利表示了感谢。我喜欢这一点。最后，这是疫情后我们第一次面对面录制播客。天哪。那真是重要的一天。
And we got this letter from Jessica B who said the giddiness in your voices at the beginning of this episode was perfection. It was so cute to hear you too that excited just to be in the same room together. And we just got a lot of mail people commenting that they felt like our chemistry was just off the charts and they were so happy we were all together again. Oh, that makes me happy. I mean, we were emotional that day for many reasons. We were super happy.
我们收到了杰西卡·B 的来信，她说这一集开头你们声音里的那种兴奋感简直完美。听到你们俩因为能待在同一个房间里而如此兴奋，真是太可爱了。我们收到了很多邮件，人们评论说他们觉得我们的化学反应简直爆表，看到我们重新聚在一起，他们非常高兴。哦，这让我很高兴。我是说，那天我们因为很多原因都很激动。我们超级开心。
We were also just like the journey we had all been through collectively. Yeah, lots of feelings. Well, this brought up a question that I have for you, Angela. Okay. Do you remember in the early days you would come to the podcast with all your note cards and you'd spread them out all over the table? Oh, yeah, like the first couple of months when we were in studio. Of course.
我们当时也感慨万千，回想起我们共同经历的旅程。是的，感触良多。好吧，这引出了我有一个关于你的问题，安吉拉。好的。你还记得在早期，你会带着所有的笔记卡来录播客，然后把它们铺满整个桌子吗？哦，是的，就像我们在录音室的前几个月一样。当然。
But then when we had to go remote and move into our closets, you didn't have room for your note cards. You were like balancing them. on all kinds of stuff. I know. You know, at the start of our podcast in 2019, we had this huge table, like you said, and I could spread them all out. And then I moved into Josh's closet right by all of his baseball hats. And I did.
但后来我们不得不远程办公，搬进各自的衣橱时，你就没有地方放笔记卡了。你当时把它们平衡在各种东西上。我知道。你知道，2019 年我们刚开始做播客时，我们有一张大桌子，就像你说的，我可以把它们全部铺开。然后我搬进了乔什的衣橱，就在他所有的棒球帽旁边。我确实那样做了。
I tried to balance my cards everywhere. I would drop them. I'd be shuffling through them because I couldn't spread them out. And I migrated to a document. You did. Okay. So this is my question because we talked about that, how you now worked off a document. document. Well, lady, I will tell you, you have seen my documents. They are in all different colors.
我试着把卡片平衡在各处。我会把它们弄掉。我会翻来翻去地找，因为我没法把它们铺开。于是我改用了文档。你确实改了。好的。所以这是我的问题，因为我们谈过这个，你现在是如何使用文档工作的。文档。好吧，女士，我会告诉你，你见过我的文档。它们有各种不同的颜色。
It's true. They're color coded. Yeah. So I highlighted portions. So like I would, in my note card days, I would have yellow note cards and pink ones and green ones. And they kind of meant different things to me, like my blue note cards for like deleted scenes. So I would know, okay, I put all the deleted scenes on blue note cards. And then, you know, little tidbits or fan catches or background catches. So I do that now. I go through my document and I have green sections and red sections. And I used to print out my documents. And I don't know if you've noticed, but now I just read off my laptop. Yeah. You want to know why? Why? I keep running out of ink. You're running out of the colored ink. Yes. I'm like, Josh, I need more colored ink. I'm paperless now. Oh my gosh. You went from note cards to a document to paperless.
是真的。它们是按颜色编码的。是的。所以我高亮了部分内容。就像我在用笔记卡的时候，我会用黄色的笔记卡，还有粉色的和绿色的。它们对我来说意味着不同的事情，比如我的蓝色笔记卡是用来记录删除场景的。所以我知道，好的，我把所有的删除场景都放在蓝色笔记卡上。然后，你知道，一些小花絮、粉丝发现或背景细节。我现在也这样做。我浏览我的文档，我有绿色部分和红色部分。我过去常把文档打印出来。我不知道你有没有注意到，但现在我只是看着笔记本电脑读。是的。你想知道为什么吗？为什么？我的墨水总是用完。你的彩色墨水用完了。是的。我就说，乔什，我需要更多的彩色墨水。我现在无纸化了。天哪。你从笔记卡到文档，再到无纸化。
Well, today you and I are recording a bunch of different things. And so I have a combo. I'm paperless, but then look what's on my keyboard. You have four. Four sticky notes to remind you of things. Yes. So I guess I still, every once in a while, I'll go back to a little post-it that I stick onto my laptop to remind me of a few things. Well, you know, people are always curious. How do we prepare our podcasts?
好吧，今天你和我正在录制很多不同的东西。所以我有一个组合。我无纸化了，但你看我的键盘上有什么。你有四个。四个便利贴来提醒你一些事情。是的。所以我猜我偶尔还是会回到贴在笔记本电脑上的小便利贴，提醒自己一些事情。好吧，你知道，人们总是很好奇。我们是如何准备播客的？
And we put a lot of time and effort and research into them, whatever the subject is. And we share a little bit with each other, like, I'll tackle this, you tackle that. But we like to surprise each other as well. Yeah. So we also keep separate documents. You know, my daughter said something the other day. She's working on a paper. She's a junior in high school.
我们投入了大量的时间、精力和研究，无论主题是什么。我们会互相分享一点，比如，我负责这个，你负责那个。但我们也喜欢给对方惊喜。是的。所以我们也保留单独的文档。你知道，我女儿前几天说了些什么。她正在写一篇论文。她是高二学生。
And she knows you and I do our documents, you know? And she said, wow, mom, you know one thing you and Jenna have in common? I was like, what? She goes, you guys are both really good research writers. That is a high compliment. Isn't it? I appreciate that. And I said that means I do really enjoy that part of it.
她知道你和我都在做文档，你知道吗？她说，哇，妈妈，你知道你和珍娜有一个共同点吗？我说，什么？她说，你们俩都是非常出色的研究型写作者。那真是极高的赞美。不是吗？我很感激。我说这意味着我真的很享受那部分工作。
I love to see what you're going to dig up and vice versa. and we kind of build the show together. Yeah. And we both like to dig in and research new things. We do. All right. Well, listen, everybody. That's all we got.
我喜欢看你会挖掘出什么，反之亦然。我们一起构建节目。是的。我们都喜欢深入研究新事物。我们确实喜欢。好了，听着，各位。这就是我们所有的内容了。
Now here is your second drink of weight loss part one. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of the Office
现在是你的《减肥》第一部分特饮。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，
and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the Office ladies. Hi, everyone. Hey! Oh my gosh! We are kicking off season five of the office with Weight Loss Part 1. Season flipping five.
并提供只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。大家好。嘿！天哪！我们正在开启《办公室》第五季，第一集是《减肥》第一部分。翻篇第五季了。
Yeah. We're here. Here we are. Let's do it. This is season five, episode one written by Lee Eisenberg and Gene Stepnitsky, directed by Paul Feig. We stop talking. We've already don't know what we're doing in here. You know what I was going to do?
是的。我们到了。我们在这儿。开始吧。这是第五季第一集，由李·艾森伯格和吉恩·斯图普尼茨基编剧，保罗·费格执导。我们别说话了。我们已经不知道在这里做什么了。你知道我本来要做什么吗？
I was going to go, bo-be-pooh, boo! And then I was like, no. Well, that's annoying. So then I said nothing. And then you said nothing, and then we just stared at each other. You know why? Because we can. There might be a lot of long pauses in this podcast today.
我本来想说，bo-be-pooh, boo！然后我就想，不。好吧，那很烦人。所以我什么也没说。然后你什么也没说，我们就只是盯着对方看。你知道为什么吗？因为我们可以。今天这个播客里可能会有很多长时间的停顿。
I'm going to move us into a summary. The gang at Dunder Mifflin participates in an eight-week company-wide weight loss competition. Pam begins her three-month design program in New York City, and Andy attempts to get Angela to commit to wedding plans. but she's busy. She's having an affair with Dwight, an affair. I know. She is stressed the F out. And the minute Andy asks her about the wedding, she runs to Dwight. Yeah. I have a question about that. Why can't you guys like have sex at home, like after work? Are you guys having sex at home after work or is it only in the warehouse? That is such a good question I've never thought about. I mean, I definitely see their hookups in this episode whenever Angela is spiraling.
我要进入总结环节。邓德·米夫林的团队参加了一场为期八周的全公司减肥比赛。帕姆在纽约市开始她的三个月设计课程，安迪试图让安吉拉承诺婚礼计划。但她很忙。她和德怀特有外遇，一段外遇。我知道。她压力大得要命。安迪一问她关于婚礼的事，她就跑去找德怀特。是的。我对此有个问题。为什么你们不能在家里，比如下班后发生关系？你们是在下班后在家里发生关系，还是只在仓库里？这是一个很好的问题，我从来没想过。我是说，我确实在这一集里看到了他们的偷情，每当安吉拉情绪崩溃时。
Yeah. Maybe she's happy at home with all of her cats, and maybe she doesn't let Andy come over. So she doesn't need Dwight to cope. Yeah. Or maybe they're just shagging everywhere. I don't know. Well, we'll discuss more later. We'll discuss more.
是的。也许她在家里和所有的猫在一起很开心，也许她不让安迪过来。所以她不需要德怀特来应对。是的。或者他们只是到处乱搞。我不知道。好吧，我们稍后再讨论。我们会讨论更多的。
Guys, this was the start of our fifth season, like we said. And to make up for the shorter fourth season that got interrupted because of the writer's strike, NBC ordered 28 episodes for season five. So this season has the most episodes of any office season. Oh my God, I didn't know that. Yeah. That's some good office trivia, my lady. Thank you. Thank you. Well, it's going to move us into fast fact number one, which is a little complicated. I'll tell you why. Okay. Back at the end of season three, we said that Rashida Jones left the show and stopped playing Karen Philippa. She had to go do parks and recreation. Was she not going to do parks and rec then?
伙计们，这是我们第五季的开始，就像我们说的。为了弥补因编剧罢工而中断的较短的第四季，NBC 为第五季预订了 28 集。所以这一季是《办公室》所有季度中集数最多的一季。天哪，我不知道。是的。那是一些很棒的《办公室》冷知识，我的女士。谢谢。谢谢。好吧，这要带我们进入第一个冷知识，这有点复杂。我告诉你为什么。好的。回到第三季末，我们说拉什达·琼斯离开了剧组，不再扮演凯伦·菲利帕。她不得不去拍《公园与游憩》。她当时不是不去拍《公园与游憩》吗？
She wasn't, Ang, because parks and recreation did not exist yet. Parks and recreation does not exist until the middle of season five of the office. Oh, farts. We got that wrong, milady. We did. Why am I saying milady? I don't know. Is the milady the new lady?
她没有，安吉，因为《公园与游憩》当时还没出现。《公园与游憩》直到《办公室》第五季中期才出现。哦，该死。我们弄错了，女士。我们确实错了。为什么我一直说女士？我不知道。女士是新的“女士”吗？
I hope not because people right now are like, my ears are bleeding. Stop saying milady. Wait, so Rashida, was she leaving to do a different project? No, she left because they finished the storyline of Karen, Jim, and Pam. It was a storyline thing. I mean, she did go on to do more projects. She did a bunch of movies in that time. Right, right, right. But no, it was a storyline thing. Similarly, I'll have you know that we wondered during Branch Wars if the photo of Hillary Clinton in her office was a nod to Leslie Knope loving Hillary Clinton. We thought that it was. It wasn't because, again, there was no Leslie Knope. There was. was no Parks and Rec yet. We were determined to pull up Parks and Rec by a few years. Well, I love Parks and Rec, so. I know. Okay. Well, there you go. We got that wrong. So this is important for two reasons. One, we need to know the timeline of Parks and Rec. Clearly. And number two, Greg Daniels, who created the American version of the office, he created Parks and Rec, along with one of our
我希望不是，因为现在人们会说，我的耳朵在流血。别再叫女士了。等等，所以拉什达，她是离开去拍别的项目了吗？不，她离开是因为他们完成了凯伦、吉姆和帕姆的故事线。这是一个故事线的问题。我是说，她后来确实去做了更多的项目。她在那个时期拍了很多电影。对，对，对。但不是，这是一个故事线的问题。同样，我要告诉你，我们在《分部战争》时想知道，她办公室里希拉里·克林顿的照片是否是对莱斯利·诺普热爱希拉里·克林顿的致敬。我们以为是。其实不是，因为，再说一次，当时没有莱斯利·诺普。还没有《公园与游憩》。我们当时一心想把《公园与游憩》提前几年。好吧，我喜欢《公园与游憩》，所以。我知道。好的。好吧，就是这样。我们弄错了。所以这很重要，有两个原因。第一，我们需要知道《公园与游憩》的时间线。很明显。第二，格雷格·丹尼尔斯，他创作了美版《办公室》，他创作了《公园与游憩》，还有我们的一位
writers, Mike Shore. So, midway through this season five, we're going to lose both Greg and Mike because they're going to be working on Parks and Rec. And that is why Jen Salada and Paul Lieberstein take over as the showrunners for season five. All right. There you go. Now, Mike sure moved to Parks and Rec full time. Greg was doing both shows. Greg did a little bit of Parks and Rec. He did a little office. He bounced back and forth. He did. Yes. Just wanted us to get that timeline correct. Yes. All right. Fast fact number two. Writer of this episode, Gene Stupnitsky, said that the idea for a weight loss episode had been on the writer's wall for a really long time. But they couldn't figure out how to do it in one day.
编剧，迈克·舒尔。所以，在第五季中期，我们将失去格雷格和迈克，因为他们将去制作《公园与游憩》。这就是为什么珍·萨拉达和保罗·利伯斯坦接手担任第五季的剧集主管。好了。就是这样。现在，迈克·舒尔全职转到了《公园与游憩》。格雷格两部剧都做。格雷格做了一点《公园与游憩》。他做了一点《办公室》。他来回奔波。他确实做了。是的。只是想让我们把时间线弄对。是的。好的。第二个冷知识。这一集的编剧吉恩·斯图普尼茨基说，减肥这一集的想法在编剧墙上已经挂了很长时间了。但他们想不出怎么在一天内完成。
Because remember, they had that rule where they tried to have plot lines that only cover one work day. Right. When NBC asked for the premiere of season five to be an hour long, Greg Daniels had the idea that we could do the weight loss episode as a sort of summer retrospective. Right, because we never see the characters over the summer. Yeah, Jean said this was a really cool opportunity to see the characters over their summertime and that they almost called this episode summer. Huh. You might notice also for this episode, there is no cold open. It just starts with the opening credits.
因为记住，他们有那个规则，试图让情节线只覆盖一个工作日。对。当 NBC 要求第五季的首播集为一个小时长时，格雷格·丹尼尔斯有个想法，我们可以把减肥这一集作为一种夏季回顾。对，因为我们从没见过角色们度过夏天。是的，吉恩说这是一个非常酷的机会，可以看到角色们度过夏天，他们差点把这一集叫作《夏天》。哈。你可能还会注意到，这一集没有冷开场。它直接以片头字幕开始。
Gene said that there was a cold open in the script. It was written that way, but they actually just folded it in to the plot. And he said that the pacing of this episode is a little quicker than previous seasons. This is going to become kind of our new pacing moving forward and that this was a change they made so they could fit in more jokes and more supporting character storylines. I mean, I definitely noticed. I felt like it clipped along. Yes. Fast fact number three, this episode has an all-cru commentary. Angela, take it away. It does, you guys, when I started listening to this DVD commentary and realized it was all crew, I called Jenna right away.
吉恩说剧本里有一个冷开场。它是那样写的，但他们实际上只是把它融入了情节中。他说这一集的节奏比前几季快一点。这将成为我们未来的一种新节奏，这是他们做出的改变，这样他们就能塞进更多的笑话和更多的配角故事线。我是说，我确实注意到了。我觉得它节奏很快。是的。第三个冷知识，这一集有全剧组评论。安吉拉，你来吧。确实，伙计们，当我开始听这个 DVD 评论并意识到全是剧组人员时，我立刻给珍娜打了电话。
it was one of the best DVD commentaries I've listened to up until now. It's so good. And you've listened to all of them. I have. And I want to share with you guys who is on this DVD commentary for weight loss. Okay. It's phenomenal. It's great. So much information. At the beginning of the DVD commentary, everyone in the crew went around said their names and their job title for this episode. Okay. Randy Cordray, our brand new line producer, Michael Gallenberg, our production designer. Brian Whittle, our boom operator. Nick Carbone, our sound utility. Ben Patrick, our production sound mixer. Alicia Raycraft, our new costume designer.
这是我迄今为止听过的最好的 DVD 评论之一。太棒了。而且你把它们全听了。我听了。我想和你们分享一下谁在《减肥》的 DVD 评论里。好的。太惊人了。太棒了。信息量很大。在 DVD 评论的开头，剧组里的每个人都轮流说了他们的名字和这一集的职位。好的。兰迪·科德雷，我们全新的制片经理，迈克尔·加伦伯格，我们的美术指导。布莱恩·惠特尔，我们的吊杆操作员。尼克·卡博内，我们的音效助理。本·帕特里克，我们的现场混音师。艾丽西亚·雷克拉夫特，我们新的服装设计师。
Kelly Cantley, our first assistant director. And Jake oust, our post-producer. Oh, my gosh. What was it like to hear all of their voices again? It was so wonderful. And, you know, Kelly Cantley, I loved her so much. And Jenna, we still are on each other's Christmas card list. We send each other Christmas cards every year.
凯利·坎特利，我们的第一副导演。还有杰克·奥斯特，我们的后期制片人。天哪。再次听到他们的声音是什么感觉？太美妙了。而且，你知道，我非常爱凯利·坎特利。而且珍娜，我们仍然在彼此的圣诞贺卡名单上。我们每年都给对方寄圣诞贺卡。
and I just adore her. And I texted her. I said, Kelly, I can't tell you how wonderful it is. I just spent an hour with you, like listening to your voice. I miss you so much. And she was like, Angie, I miss you too. And I get her Christmas cards too from her and her husband, Kevin, and their two dogs. I look forward to them every year. There is so much awesome information about the making of weight loss one and two. First thing I want to share with you guys that this was Randy and Alicia's first episode that they ever worked on on the office. And what an enormous huge way to start their time on the show. So normally, one episode, as Jenna said, is one day, they had to take our show over the course of eight weeks in one episode. It was a continuity
我简直太爱她了。我给她发了短信。我说，凯利，我无法告诉你这有多美妙。我刚刚和你待了一个小时，就像听你的声音一样。我太想你了。她说，安吉，我也想你。我也收到她和她丈夫凯文以及他们的两只狗寄来的圣诞贺卡。我每年都很期待。关于《减肥》第一和第二部分的制作，有太多很棒的信息。我想和你们分享的第一件事是，这是兰迪和艾丽西亚参与制作的第一集《办公室》。以如此巨大的方式开始他们在剧组的时间。所以通常情况下，正如珍娜所说，一集是一天，他们必须在一集中把我们的节目跨越八周。这简直是连续性
nightmare. For Alicia, wardrobe had eight changes. And Jenna, you and I love tracking things. Well, guess who else loves tracking things? Alicia. Kelly Cantley. Oh, boy. Kelly Cantley. She listed off all of the things that they would have to track over weight loss one and two. I loved it so much. I wrote it down, and I began to track it as well. Number one, eight wardrobe changes. Number two, eight set dressings of the main office bullpen. Number three, was it raining or not raining outside the windows, depending on the scene? Number four, they had three different goatee beards on Michael Ryan and Dwight. number five meridus sunburned face we'll get to that number six the dry erase board with everyone's weight loss stats number seven the fruit flies and number eight the rotting of fruit wow that's what they
噩梦。对于艾丽西亚来说，服装有八次更换。珍娜，你和我喜欢追踪事情。好吧，猜猜还有谁喜欢追踪事情？艾丽西亚。凯利·坎特利。哦，天哪。凯利·坎特利。她列出了他们在《减肥》第一和第二部分中必须追踪的所有事情。我太喜欢了。我把它写了下来，我也开始追踪它。第一，八次服装更换。第二，八次主要办公室大厅的场景布置。第三，窗外是在下雨还是没下雨，取决于场景？第四，他们在迈克尔、瑞安和德怀特身上有三个不同的山羊胡。第五，梅雷迪思晒伤的脸，我们稍后会讲到。第六，带有每个人减肥数据的干擦板。第七，果蝇。第八，水果腐烂。哇，这就是他们
were keeping track of so many things and then lastly this episode was a huge challenge for the editing department do you remember in goodbye toby how i had the script i had the shooting draft and I kept telling you how the scenes were all rearranged differently for the episode that actually aired. Yeah. Well, Jake shared in the commentary that Greg and the writers were very used to being able to just move scenes around and kind of change how the episode would take shape. And they could not do that in this episode because it's week to week and everything progresses week to week within one episode. And you can't move around that story. No. And our clothes are changing, right? Yes.
在追踪的事情，最后，这一集对剪辑部门来说是一个巨大的挑战。你还记得在《再见托比》中，我有剧本，我有拍摄草稿，我一直告诉你场景是如何为实际播出的剧集重新排列的吗？是的。好吧，杰克在评论中分享说，格雷格和编剧们非常习惯于能够随意移动场景，并改变剧集的成型方式。但他们在这一集中做不到，因为它是每周进行的，一切都在一集中每周推进。你不能移动那个故事。不。而且我们的衣服在变，对吧？是的。
Like you'd notice, but there is, I saw a little flub. Yes, well, you'll have to bring that up. And they also address, and I'll bring this up when it happens, a character that they had to keep digitally changing their shirt. What? Yes. I'll share when we get to the moment. Angela, I think you need to do fast facts more often because that is possibly one of my favorite fast facts we've ever done. Well, I'm giving you fast fact number three from now on.
就像你会注意到的，但我看到了一个小失误。是的，好吧，你得提出来。他们还提到了，我会在它发生时提出来，一个必须不断数字化更换衬衫的角色。什么？是的。我会分享我们到达那一刻的时候。安吉拉，我觉得你需要更频繁地做冷知识，因为那可能是我做过的最喜欢的冷知识之一。好吧，从现在开始我把冷知识交给你。
I bet you are. Thanks. I know. You guys, Fast Facts are really hard. Fass Facts are really hard. Jenna created Fast Facts for herself and then was like, Angela, these dang fast facts. I wish every week the crew did the DVD commentary is what I wish, because it's the best commentary. It was the most insightful, interesting, the best background trivia. Fast FAC 3 was easy because of our crew's commentary. I cannot wait to watch that payoff as we break down this episode. Let's take a break. Shocker, I need to go to the bathroom. You know, we've had a big morning. It was a reunion.
我打赌你会的。谢谢。我知道。伙计们，冷知识真的很难。冷知识真的很难。珍娜为自己创造了冷知识，然后说，安吉拉，这些该死的冷知识。我希望每周剧组都能做 DVD 评论，这是我的愿望，因为这是最好的评论。这是最有洞察力、最有趣、最好的背景琐事。冷知识 3 很简单，因为有我们剧组的评论。我迫不及待地想在剖析这一集时看到那个回报。让我们休息一下。震惊的是，我需要去洗手间。你知道，我们度过了一个忙碌的早晨。这是一次重聚。
We both drank lots of beverages. All right, we're going to go to the restroom. We'll be right back. All right, well, we are back. Everyone is in the conference room. They are having a feast. I mean, there is a buffet of food happening here. Yeah, well, Michael tells everyone they better eat up because it's their last meal.
我们都喝了很多饮料。好吧，我们要去洗手间。我们马上回来。好的，我们回来了。每个人都在会议室里。他们正在享用盛宴。我是说，这里正在举行自助餐。是的，迈克尔告诉每个人他们最好吃个够，因为这是他们的最后一餐。
They're going to start this weight loss competition, but first they're trying to bulk up. So that when they lose weight, number is big. There's a big difference. Yes, exactly. Dwight has also told people they can't even use the bathroom. You're going to have to hold it. They want maximum poundage on the scale. And the stakes are high because Michael explains that this is a corporate weight loss challenge, and the branch that loses the most weight wins three whole extra vacation days. Everyone's excited. Yeah. I paused and I went frame by frame and I made a list of all the food I could see. I love this. This is reminding me a little bit of my pizza by Alfredo moment. Is it going to be 10 minutes?
他们要开始这场减肥比赛，但首先他们试图增重。这样当他们减肥时，数字会很大。有很大的区别。是的，没错。德怀特还告诉人们他们甚至不能使用洗手间。你们得憋着。他们想要秤上的最大重量。赌注很高，因为迈克尔解释说这是一场企业减肥挑战赛，减掉最多体重的分部将赢得整整三天的额外假期。每个人都很兴奋。是的。我暂停了，我逐帧查看，我列出了我能看到的所有食物。我喜欢这个。这让我想起了一点我的“阿尔弗雷多披萨”时刻。会是 10 分钟吗？
No, there's not that much food. Okay, let's hear it. All right. There is a chocolate fondue fountain. There is a cheese fondue fountain. There are marshmallows, fried chicken, ribs, maybe some waffles, cornbread muffins, donuts, lots of soda, mac and cheese, dumplings. I swear someone has mashed potatoes and gravy on their plate. And then Jim has some strawberries on his plate, probably for the chocolate fountain. But I was surprised to spot a bit of healthy food. Not surprised to see it on John Krasinski's plate, however. He was such a healthy eater. He was. Jenna, do you know what I remember about this scene? What? How funky that cheese got. Yeah. It got real smelly. Yeah. Kelly shares on the DVD that they could only keep that cheese
不，没有那么多食物。好的，说来听听。好的。有一个巧克力火锅喷泉。有一个奶酪火锅喷泉。有棉花糖、炸鸡、排骨、可能还有一些华夫饼、玉米松饼、甜甜圈、很多苏打水、通心粉和奶酪、饺子。我发誓有人盘子里有土豆泥和肉汁。然后吉姆盘子里有一些草莓，可能是为了巧克力喷泉。但我很惊讶地发现了一些健康食品。不过，在约翰·卡拉辛斯基的盘子里看到它并不奇怪。他是个非常健康的食客。他确实是。珍娜，你知道我关于这个场景记得什么吗？什么？那奶酪变得多臭。是的。它变得真的很臭。是的。凯利在 DVD 上分享说，他们只能让那奶酪
melted for three hours. It would start to like coagulate or whatever. It got so gross. I mean, that really makes me think twice about any cheese fondue fountain. The fountain food, I might be done with fountain food. When I was in college, I had a boyfriend and we read that there was like this protein shake company that was going to give a $10,000 prize to whoever lost the most weight and gain the most muscle by using their protein shake.
融化三个小时。它会开始凝结什么的。它变得太恶心了。我是说，这真的让我对任何奶酪火锅喷泉三思而后行。喷泉食物，我可能受够了喷泉食物。我在大学时，有个男朋友，我们读到有一家蛋白粉公司要给减掉最多体重并增加最多肌肉的人 10,000 美元的奖金，通过使用他们的蛋白粉。
Right. So the idea is to get healthy, lose weight, and here's your incentive is a bunch of money or something? Yeah. So we entered. You and your boyfriend? Yeah. You did the shake challenge? We did.
对。所以想法是变得健康，减肥，这是你的激励，是一大笔钱还是什么？是的。所以我们参加了。你和你的男朋友？是的。你们做了奶昔挑战？我们做了。
Here's the thing. We did the same thing. We're like in the week before. You carved up. We did. We ate a bunch of food. I probably gained about five pounds. In one week.
事情是这样的。我们做了同样的事情。我们在前一周。你增重了。我们确实做了。我们吃了很多食物。我可能胖了大约五磅。在一周内。
Yeah. Because we just like ate piece. pizza and burgers because we were like, this is great. I mean, we'll start out with more weight and then we'll lose it all and more. And we'll win $10,000. Yeah, I mean, we took pictures of ourselves. I still have it. Oh, no. I mean, somewhere I have it. I know because I was cleaning out some old photo albums and I found it and it jogged this memory. You had to prove the day, you know, of the weight loss start. Yeah. So you had to hold up that day's newspaper. I mean, like a hostage photo. Oh my God. So I've got this picture of myself. This was before you could Instagram.
是的。因为我们只是吃披萨和汉堡，因为我们想，这太棒了。我是说，我们会以更多的体重开始，然后我们会减掉它，甚至更多。我们会赢得 10,000 美元。是的，我是说，我们拍了照片。我还有。哦，不。我是说，在某个地方我有它。我知道，因为我在清理一些旧相册时发现了它，它勾起了这段记忆。你必须证明减肥开始的那一天，你知道。所以你必须举起那一天的报纸。我是说，像人质照片一样。天哪。所以我有一张自己的照片。这是在你可以在 Instagram 上发帖之前。
Now you can insestore your Instagram and it's a timestamp, but back then you had to hold up like a newspaper. Yeah. And take it with a regular old camera. I'm in like a sports bra and some like sport shorts. Mm-hmm. And I'm holding up a newspaper and I will tell you what. Not only did we not win, I did not lose any of the weight. That you gained carb loading. That's right. After the eight weeks, I mean, we gave up so quickly. We were all in for the first week of the fitness challenge. And then all that happened was from all of this is that I gained five pounds and then I held up a newspaper. The end.
现在你可以把你的 Instagram 存起来，它有一个时间戳，但那时你必须举起一份报纸。是的。并用一台普通的旧相机拍摄。我穿着运动内衣和一些运动短裤。嗯哼。我举着一份报纸，我会告诉你什么。我们不仅没有赢，我也没有减掉任何体重。你增重了碳水化合物。没错。八周后，我是说，我们很快就放弃了。我们在健身挑战的第一周全力以赴。然后发生的一切就是我胖了五磅，然后我举起了一份报纸。结束。
So that memory came flooding back as I was watching us in this conference room scene. So Stanley, Meredith, and Creed have plans for their leftovers. You know, Stanley really wants to take some of these dumplings home. But Dwight is like, no, no, you cannot take any. of this food home, we're eating healthy now, and he starts spraying what looks like an insect repellent all over all of the food. We had a fan question from Chelsea B, Alice R. and Henry F. What was in the bottle that Dwight is spraying on the food? Well, guess who knows? You? Me. Thanks to our crew. It was not real bug spray, of course. This was a prop bottle that Phil Shea had designed.
所以当我在会议室场景中看着我们时，那段记忆涌上心头。所以斯坦利、梅雷迪思和克里德对他们的剩菜有计划。你知道，斯坦利真的很想带一些饺子回家。但德怀特说，不，不，你不能带任何食物回家，我们现在吃得健康，他开始喷洒看起来像杀虫剂的东西在所有的食物上。我们有一个来自切尔西·B、爱丽丝·R 和亨利·F 的粉丝问题。德怀特喷在食物上的瓶子里是什么？好吧，猜猜谁知道？你？我。多亏了我们的剧组。当然不是真正的杀虫剂。这是一个菲尔·谢设计的道具瓶。
He had this made, and it was full of aerosol water. Oh. So he was just spraying water. You know, I assumed that's what it was, but it didn't look like water. I mean, it looked real. I thought it looked real, and I thought everyone's reactions were really good. Great acting, folks. You sold it.
他让人做了这个，里面装满了气溶胶水。哦。所以他只是在喷水。你知道，我以为那是水，但看起来不像水。我是说，它看起来很真实。我以为它看起来很真实，我觉得每个人的反应都很好。演得好，伙计们。你们演得真像。
Well, now the gang is going to go down to the warehouse. They're going to weigh in. Yes. And Jenna, at one minute, five seconds, there is a great shot of the big scale that we're all going to get weighed on, and I have a prop, a breakdown. Give it to me. Okay. That scale was custom made by Rice Lake weighing systems. They made it specific to our requests, and they were able to program the little computer screen with whatever the writers wanted them to put on it, right? It was like part of the joke. Our weight. That was all like a writer's joke. My mind is being blown right now
好吧，现在团队要下到仓库去。他们要去称重。是的。珍娜，在 1 分 05 秒，有一个大秤的精彩镜头，我们都要在上面称重，我有一个道具，一个分解。给我。好的。那个秤是莱斯湖称重系统定制的。他们根据我们的要求专门制作了它，他们能够用编剧想要的任何东西来编程那个小电脑屏幕，对吧？这就像笑话的一部分。我们的体重。那全是编剧的笑话。我的大脑现在被震撼了
that that was not a real scale. No, the scale didn't exist. It was made. just for us. And Rice Lake Wang System didn't ask for any credit or any company plug. They were huge fans of the show. And they did come to set the day we filmed this. And everyone on our crew said they were so nice. And after this episode aired, that scale stayed in the warehouse as part of the warehouse set. That I remember. Now, during this way in, Angela, what's up with Meredith's face? Did you notice. Her face is all red. We got a lot of mail about it. They want to know what's going on. Was there a storyline that was cut or something? Oh, yes. I want you guys to know I took a photo of Kate's face as Meredith looking like that. And I texted it to Kate last night. And I said, Kate, you know what?
那不是一个真正的秤。不，秤不存在。它是专门为我们制作的。而且莱斯湖称重系统没有要求任何信用或任何公司植入。他们是该剧的忠实粉丝。他们确实在我们拍摄这一天来到了片场。我们剧组的每个人都说他们人很好。在这一集播出后，那个秤留在了仓库里，作为仓库场景的一部分。我记得那个。现在，在这次称重期间，安吉拉，梅雷迪思的脸怎么了？你注意到了吗？她的脸全红了。我们收到了很多关于它的邮件。他们想知道发生了什么。有一个被剪掉的故事线吗？哦，是的。我想让你们知道，我拍了一张凯特作为梅雷迪思看起来那样的脸的照片。我昨晚把它发给了凯特。我说，凯特，你知道吗？
You should win Team Player Award for the run of the office. Because her character was always getting into some kind of mishap, which resulted in Kate being in the hair and makeup trailer forever. Right? Yeah. Yeah. And here was the storyline, and it's shared in the deleted scenes. Meredith gets severely sunburned. And here is her explanation. Sam, can you play the clip? These guys took me out in the fishing boat.
你应该赢得《办公室》运行期间的团队合作奖。因为她的角色总是陷入某种困境，导致凯特永远待在发型和化妆房里。对吧？是的。是的。这就是故事线，它在删除场景中分享了。梅雷迪思严重晒伤了。这是她的解释。萨姆，你能播放那个片段吗？这些家伙带我去了渔船。
I don't think I caught anything. Hello, hello. Hey, your face is almost back to normal. One more kid calls me Hellboy. I swear to God. Oh, you wish. Hellboy's a hero. Oh, wow.
我想我什么也没抓到。你好，你好。嘿，你的脸快恢复正常了。再有一个孩子叫我地狱男爵。我发誓。哦，你希望如此。地狱男爵是个英雄。哦，哇。
Yeah, she went out on a boat, got some. super super sunburned. And this was something they had to watch in continuity of which stage of the sunburn was her face at. Then the whole storyline got deleted, but they couldn't take out Kate's face. You know what I mean? So they just had to leave it in. And Kate said the day after the show aired, Steve came up to her on set and was like, you know what, Kate, I still thought it was funny. You know, I kind of love that Meredith has this mystery about her. Yeah. That she has this whole other life we don't even need to explain. And Kate said it made her feel so good that Steve was so thoughtful to come over and say that. Yeah. That was hard when you had a storyline and then you'd watch the episode.
是的，她坐船出去了，晒得超级超级严重。这是他们必须在连续性中观察的事情，她的脸处于晒伤的哪个阶段。然后整个故事线被删除了，但他们无法去掉凯特的脸。你知道我的意思吗？所以他们只能把它留在里面。凯特说在节目播出后的第二天，史蒂夫在片场走到她面前说，你知道吗，凯特，我仍然觉得它很有趣。你知道，我有点喜欢梅雷迪思身上有这种神秘感。是的。她有这种我们甚至不需要解释的完整生活。凯特说，史蒂夫如此体贴地走过来那样说，让她感觉很好。是的。当你有一个故事线然后看着剧集时，那很难。
They wouldn't warn you a lot of the times. You'd just watch the episode and it was gone. Yeah. And you know, with supporting cast, we were often, you know, in the B or C story. And those really got moved around a lot. Yeah. And trimmed and edited. And it did happen. But Kate, man, such a good sport. Wow. Guys, also in this scene, Michael throws Pam off the scale because she's going to go away to art school. So he doesn't want her extra poundage. Now, they've already weighed in, and then Pam gets off the scale, and a new weight is displayed. So embarrassing.
他们很多时候不会警告你。你只是看着剧集，它就消失了。是的。而且你知道，对于配角，我们经常处于 B 或 C 故事中。那些确实被移动了很多。是的。并被修剪和编辑。它确实发生了。但凯特，伙计，真是个好运动。哇。伙计们，在这个场景中，迈克尔把帕姆从秤上扔了下来，因为她要去艺术学校。所以他不想要她额外的重量。现在，他们已经称重了，然后帕姆从秤上下来，显示了一个新的重量。太尴尬了。
Everyone is clocking this number change. Yeah. We got some fan mail from Kim C who said, during the group weigh-in, it becomes clear that Pam weighs 126 pounds. Jenna, did the writers consult you about your actual weight when they added this fact, or did they just guess how much they thought you might weigh? And were you comfortable with sharing this speculation about your weight? Well, I'll tell you guys, actually, in the script, the original table draft, Pam weighed 145 pounds. And I said, you guys, this is, I feel like a weird thing for me to split hairs about, but I don't weigh 140.5 pounds. And I said, you guys, this is, I feel like a weird thing for me to split hairs about, but I don't weigh 145 pounds.
每个人都在记录这个数字变化。是的。我们收到了来自金·C 的粉丝邮件，她说，在集体称重期间，很明显帕姆重 126 磅。珍娜，编剧在添加这个事实时咨询了你的实际体重吗，还是他们只是猜测他们认为你可能有多重？你对分享这种关于你体重的猜测感到舒服吗？好吧，我会告诉你们，实际上在剧本里，最初的草稿中，帕姆重 145 磅。我说，伙计们，我觉得这是一件奇怪的事情，但我并不重 140.5 磅。我说，伙计们，我觉得这是一件奇怪的事情，但我并不重 145 磅。
It's not accurate. Why don't you just put my real weight, which at the time was 126 pounds. I don't weigh 126 pounds anymore. But at the time, that was my weight. And so they changed it. Yeah. But yeah, when they speculated about my weight, they put me at 145. and I just, I don't know, I just corrected it.
这不准确。为什么你不直接放我真实的体重，当时是 126 磅。我现在不重 126 磅了。但在当时，那是我的体重。所以他们改了。是的。但确实，当他们猜测我的体重时，他们把我定在 145 磅。我只是，我不知道，我只是纠正了它。
I thought it should be correct. I have no problem with that. Well, Jenna, that scene made me laugh just because your performance, your reaction. You watch everyone doing the math and you're just standing there. Yeah. And it was very funny the way you played that moment. Now it's week two of their weight loss contest. Oscar Nandy arrived.
我觉得它应该是正确的。我对此没有问题。好吧，珍娜，那个场景让我笑了，只是因为你的表演，你的反应。你看着每个人都在做数学题，而你只是站在那里。是的。你演绎那一刻的方式非常有趣。现在是他们减肥比赛的第二周。奥斯卡和安迪到了。
They're going to hold the elevator for Stanley. And Stanley says he forgot something and then he takes the stairs without them knowing. And he has a great talking head. where he shares that he's been losing weight on his own. And he just noticed some of your speed and fire that he's lost a little bit of his pickup and go. And he's doing this for himself. Yes. And in this talking head, he shows an old photo of himself.
他们要为斯坦利按住电梯。斯坦利说他忘了什么，然后他在他们不知道的情况下走了楼梯。他有一个很棒的谈话头。他分享说他一直在自己减肥。他只是注意到你的一些速度和火花，他失去了一点他的活力。他是在为自己做这件事。是的。在这个谈话头中，他展示了一张他自己的旧照片。
Mm-hmm. Well, we got some mail about that. People wanted to know. What is this picture? Is this from Leslie David Baker's real life? Yes. Is this young Leslie in this photo? It is young Leslie in the photo.
嗯哼。好吧，我们收到了一些关于它的邮件。人们想知道。这张照片是什么？这是来自莱斯利·大卫·贝克的真实生活吗？是的。这是照片里年轻的莱斯利吗？这是照片里年轻的莱斯利。
Oh, my gosh. I texted Leslie and he gave me all. the info. Oh, let's hear it. It's a Photoshop picture. He does not know any of the other people in the picture. They photoshopped him into it using one of his old prom photos. Oh, Leslie. I love that. Yeah. Well, they're really taking this whole get healthy fitness thing seriously. Holly is running a yoga class in the conference room. I only saw three people in attendance. Creed, Kelly, and Michael. I didn't see anyone else. Oh. Yeah. And then Michael is. so excited. He runs up to Jim as Jim is going into the bathroom and is like, did you see Holly's
天哪。我给莱斯利发了短信，他给了我所有的信息。哦，让我们听听。这是一张 Photoshop 照片。他不认识照片里的任何其他人。他们用他的一张旧毕业舞会照片把他 Photoshop 进去了。哦，莱斯利。我喜欢那个。是的。好吧，他们真的在认真对待这个变得健康的健身事情。霍莉在会议室里开瑜伽课。我只看到三个人参加。克里德、凯利和迈克尔。我没看到其他人。哦。是的。然后迈克尔非常兴奋。他跑到吉姆那里，当吉姆要去洗手间时，他说，你看到霍莉的
butt? And Jim's like, no, you know why? Because we don't do that. Friends don't talk about other friends' butts, right? And Jim is really trying to get Michael to have a little growth, right? Yep. And he's like, what have you learned about her? And Michael says, I learned that she broke her left leg twice in one year. I learned that she's allergic to sesame seeds. I learned that she has read Lonesome Dove three times and that her butt refuses to quit, you know, and Jim's like, I give up. Little sidebar moment for you. What's that? Lonesome Dove was written by Larry McMurtry, who is from my hometown of Archer City, Texas.
屁股了吗？吉姆说，不，你知道为什么吗？因为我们不那样做。朋友不谈论其他朋友的屁股，对吧？吉姆真的在试图让迈克尔有一点成长，对吧？是的。他说，你从她身上学到了什么？迈克尔说，我学到她一年内摔断了两次左腿。我学到她对芝麻过敏。我学到她读过三遍《孤独的鸽子》，而且她的屁股拒绝放弃，你知道，吉姆说，我放弃了。给你一个小侧边栏时刻。那是什么？《孤独的鸽子》是由拉里·麦克默特里写的，他来自我的家乡德克萨斯州阿彻市。
Yes. And I knew Larry, and I know his family. And Larry was this amazing prolific writer. I got so excited just to see one of his pieces of work mentioned on the office, knowing that I grew up going to his bookstore. That is so cool. Love it. You guys got to know, there's only like 1,800 people in Archer City.
是的。我认识拉里，我也认识他的家人。拉里是一位了不起的多产作家。我看到他的作品在《办公室》中被提到，知道我从小就去他的书店，我感到非常兴奋。那太酷了。喜欢它。你们必须知道，阿彻市只有大约 1,800 人。
Everybody knows everybody. We got some fan mail from Brittany. Uh-huh. She did her own little mini deep dive on on sesame seed allergies. Oh. Yeah. She did a deep dive? She did.
每个人都认识每个人。我们收到了布列塔尼的粉丝邮件。嗯哼。她对自己进行了关于芝麻过敏的小型深度挖掘。哦。是的。她进行了深度挖掘？她做了。
She said that she would like us to know that sesame seed allergies are actually the ninth most common type of food allergy. I did not know that. Do you have any allergies? I do. I'm allergic to sweet potatoes. Crazy. Yeah. I found that out late.
她说她想让我们知道，芝麻过敏实际上是第九大最常见的食物过敏类型。我不知道。你有什么过敏吗？我有。我对红薯过敏。疯狂。是的。我发现得很晚。
in life because my mom would only make sweet potatoes at Thanksgiving. And I'm sorry, Mom, but they always looked really gross to me. So I just never even ate them. I don't know if I had some sort of like visceral kind of instinct that I shouldn't eat them. Yeah, but I never ate them. And then my first Thanksgiving in Los Angeles, I couldn't go home. I couldn't afford it. So me and my friends, we had our own Thanksgiving and someone brought some sweet potatoes that looked effing amazing. So I had some. The next day I got super sick. I wrote it off. I had taken some of those sweet potatoes home as a leftover. I ate them again, got super sick again. That's when the doctor was like, I think you should stop being sweet potatoes. I got an allergy test. And I am allergic to sweet potatoes. My daughter has a mild allergy to dairy. But you can really tell, like if she's had ice cream and stuff, she'll get really stuffy. Oh, yeah.
因为我妈只会在感恩节做红薯。抱歉了妈，但在我眼里它们看起来真的很恶心。所以我从来都不吃。我不知道自己是不是有一种本能，觉得不该吃它们。总之我从来没吃过。后来我在洛杉矶过了第一个感恩节，没法回家，因为负担不起路费。我和朋友们办了自己的感恩节聚餐，有人带了红薯来，看起来简直棒极了。于是我吃了一些。第二天我病得非常厉害。我没当回事。我把剩下的一些红薯带回了家。我又吃了一次，结果又病得很重。那时候医生就说，我觉得你不该再吃红薯了。我做了过敏测试，结果我对红薯过敏。我女儿对乳制品有轻微过敏。但你真的能看出来，如果她吃了冰淇淋之类的东西，她就会变得鼻塞。哦，是的。
Yeah. A lot of people have like a lactose intolerance that causes like some kind of like diarrhea. Well, this is our spinoff podcast. It's called What Food Studio? Body fluids and other stories. I mean, since we're on the subject of milk and stuff, I just want to say, guys, don't give milk to cats. Oh yeah, it makes them sick. Yeah. It's like a thing that's been passed down in these cartoons forever. You give cats a dish of milk. They are allergic. to the dairy and milk. Don't give it to them. Can I add to your milk with cats thing? Oh, yeah.
是的。很多人有乳糖不耐受，会导致某种腹泻。好吧，这是我们的衍生播客。叫《什么食物工作室？体液及其他故事》。既然我们聊到了牛奶之类的话题，我想说，伙计们，别给猫喂牛奶。哦，是的，那会让它们生病。是的。这就像是动画片里流传已久的事情。你给猫一碟牛奶。它们对乳制品和牛奶过敏。别喂给它们。我能补充一下你关于猫和牛奶的话题吗？哦，好的。
Don't give bread to ducks. Oh, bread to ducks. You know what? You can give them. What? Peas. Oh, peas. And bird seed.
别给鸭子喂面包。哦，鸭子吃面包。你知道吗？你可以喂它们什么？什么？豌豆。哦，豌豆。还有鸟食。
Okay. More food talk for you. Three minutes, 49 seconds. Dwight is replacing the junk food in the vending machine with fruit. Now, Kelly Cantley said this scene, which I timed at seven seconds, took them one hour to shoot. Because of the like banging the fruit in with the hammer, just all of it ripping everything out, resetting it, putting the fruit in. It took them an hour to do a seven second scene. Coming up as a really awkward scene in so many ways. So many. Oscar is going to offer to set Holly up
好的。继续聊聊食物。三分四十九秒。德怀特正在用水果替换自动售货机里的垃圾食品。现在，凯利·坎特利说这一幕——我计时了，只有七秒钟——他们拍了一个小时。因为要用锤子把水果敲进去，还要把所有东西拆出来，重置，再把水果放进去。拍一个七秒钟的镜头花了一个小时。接下来是一个在很多方面都非常尴尬的场景。非常尴尬。奥斯卡要主动提出帮霍莉介绍对象
with his yoga instructor. Mm-hmm. I feel like that was awkward number one. I mean, it's jumping in real quick being matchmaker. Yeah. I always feel like you wait for someone to ask you to set them up because there are so many assumptions you're making about their life and their preferences when you offer to set them up. Right? Yeah. I don't know. Also, like, how long has he known her?
介绍给他的瑜伽教练。嗯。我觉得那是尴尬之最。我的意思是，作为媒人介入得太快了。是的。我总觉得你应该等别人请求你帮忙介绍，因为当你主动提出介绍时，你对他们的生活和偏好做了太多假设。对吧？是的。我不知道。还有，他认识她多久了？
Have they hung out? Like, what does he know about Holly? Right. This takes us to front reception. And Jim is making sure Pam is all packed for New York. He's holding a box of her items she's going to take with her. Did you notice at four minutes, 47 seconds, what is in the box that is so important it's got to travel to New York City with Pam? Apparently, her weird spindly, plasticy desk decoration.
他们一起出去玩过吗？他到底了解霍莉什么？对。这把我们带到了前台。吉姆正在确保帕姆为去纽约打包好了一切。他拿着一个装有她要带走的物品的盒子。你在四分四十七秒时注意到盒子里有什么东西那么重要，非得跟着帕姆去纽约市吗？显然，是她那个奇怪的、细长的、塑料制的桌面装饰品。
She can't live without it. I put the multicolored sphere bobble thing. Yeah, we've talked about it on the podcast before. I get that maybe she needed to clear her desk for whoever's filling in for her. Just leave the box. Yeah. Put it in a store room and get it out when you get back. There's nothing in that box you need at Pratt, Pam.
她没有它就活不下去。我放了那个多色球体摆件。是的，我们在播客里讨论过它。我明白也许她需要清理桌面给接替她的人用。那就把盒子留下。是的。把它放在储藏室里，等你回来再拿出来。那个盒子里没有什么东西是你去普拉特艺术学院需要的，帕姆。
Nothing. But Pam has a talking head. It's super cute. I loved doing it where I say, what up to 112. I hate to tell you, Pam, the area code for Pratt, which is located in Brooklyn, is 718. Oh, Pam. But it's okay. You're trying to be all New Yorkie.
什么都没有。但帕姆有一个采访镜头。超级可爱。我很喜欢拍那个镜头，我说“112区号，你好”。我不想打击你，帕姆，位于布鲁克林的普拉特艺术学院的区号是718。哦，帕姆。但没关系。你是在努力表现得很有纽约范儿。
You're trying to be cool. Yeah, that's the Manhattan area code. Mm-hmm. Well, at five minutes, 13 seconds, there's going to be a storyline that starts, which is Andy and Angela wedding planning. There's lots of delicious stuff. There's lots more in deleted scenes. All of this wedding planning is just absolutely stressing Angela out and making her more and more irritated at Andy. This is how he walks up to her.
你是在努力装酷。是的，那是曼哈顿的区号。嗯。好吧，在五分十三秒，有一个故事线开始了，就是安迪和安吉拉的婚礼筹备。有很多精彩的内容。删减片段里还有更多。所有的婚礼筹备工作让安吉拉压力巨大，让她对安迪越来越恼火。这就是他走向她的方式。
Ang, Ella. Ella, Ella, Ella, under my Angelella. Ella, Ella, Ella, Ella, Ella, A, A. What? I loved it so much. That's how they're starting their conversation. And he's excited. He says every little boy fantasizes about his fairy tale wedding.
安吉拉，艾拉，艾拉，艾拉，在我的安吉拉之下。艾拉，艾拉，艾拉，艾拉，艾拉，A，A。什么？我太喜欢了。他们就是这样开始对话的。他很兴奋。他说每个小男孩都幻想过自己的童话婚礼。
And ding, ding, ding, this is when they had to go in and digitally change his shirt and tie in post-production because the writers wanted to move this talking head here. It had been in a different place in the story. His tie and his shirt are digital. Because they had to make it match. The scene with Angela. That's right. My mind is blown.
叮，叮，叮，这就是他们必须在后期制作中通过数字技术修改他的衬衫和领带的时候，因为编剧想把这个采访镜头移到这里。它原本在故事里的位置不同。他的领带和衬衫是数字合成的。因为他们必须让它与安吉拉的场景匹配。没错。我惊呆了。
Oh, yeah. They had to change all of that in post so they could move this talking head up. Well, in the scene with Angela, he is suggesting that they get married at the breakers in Rhode Island, this famous estate. Angela doesn't like it. He said this is really important to his family because this is where his parents decided not to get divorced. How romantic. Yes, that's where you want to get married. I looked this place up.
哦，是的。他们必须在后期修改所有这些，这样才能把这个采访镜头移上来。好吧，在与安吉拉的场景中，他建议他们在罗德岛的“断路器”庄园结婚，那是一个著名的庄园。安吉拉不喜欢。他说这对他的家庭非常重要，因为这是他父母决定不离婚的地方。多浪漫啊。是的，这就是你想结婚的地方。我查了这个地方。
It was built back. In 1893, as a summer home. Wow. Not even a main residence. It was built by the Vanderbilt family. It cost $7 million to build back then. Back then. Back then.
它建于1893年，作为避暑别墅。哇。甚至不是主要住所。它是由范德比尔特家族建造的。在当时造价就高达700万美元。在当时。在当时。
It took two years. Is it massive? Yeah. There are 70 rooms in the house. The Great Hall. 70 rooms for their summer residence. Right. And the Great Hall has 45 foot ceilings.
它花了两年时间。它很大吗？是的。房子里有70个房间。大厅。70个房间作为他们的避暑住所。对。而且大厅有45英尺高的天花板。
There's a gold. room. Okay. That was actually built in Europe and then shipped to the United States and reassembled in Newport. Good Lord. It is estimated to be worth $150 million today. That one room? No, the whole house. Oh. I know. I see how you went there because of the way I structured that. Oh my gosh. So, $150 million? Yeah. It now belongs to the Preservation Society of Newport. Port County. It is available for tours. It gets about 300,000 visitors annually. But get this. Great grandchildren still live there on the third floor during the summer. Oh, my God. But you can't tour their private residence area when you tour the house. This is like going to Bucky Kim Palace. I always wonder
有一个黄金房间。好吧。那实际上是在欧洲建造的，然后运到美国，在纽波特重新组装。天哪。据估计，它今天价值1.5亿美元。就那一个房间？不，整栋房子。哦。我知道，我明白你为什么会那么想，因为我刚才的措辞。天哪。所以，1.5亿美元？是的。它现在属于纽波特县保护协会。它对外开放参观。每年大约有30万游客。但你听着，曾孙们夏天仍然住在三楼。天哪。但当你参观房子时，你不能参观他们的私人居住区。这就像去白金汉宫一样。我总是好奇
about that. Like you live there, but there's tours. Yeah, what is that? I don't know. 70 rooms. Maybe you don't even know. Are you not giving tours of your home, Angela, to tourists while you live there? You're welcome to come over. The hall bathroom, you have to jiggle the handle. It's a double flusher. You know, it doesn't quite do it the first time. Well, all of this wedding planning stresses Angela out, and she immediately pages Dwight. And they rendezvous in the warehouse. Angela comes out of the little warehouse. I don't even know what you call it. Storage room where they meet up. And she says, look, that was the last time. I have a fiancé. I very much like. All right, Jenna, there are deleted scenes that throughout Weight Loss 1 and 2 really show Angela struggling between
关于这一点。你住在那里，但有游客参观。是的，那是什么情况？我不知道。70个房间。也许你甚至不知道。安吉拉，你不会在住的时候给游客参观你的家吧？欢迎过来。大厅的洗手间，你得晃动把手。它是双重冲水的。你知道，第一次冲不干净。好吧，所有的婚礼筹备工作让安吉拉压力很大，她立刻传呼了德怀特。他们在仓库里会合。安吉拉从那个小仓库里出来。我甚至不知道该怎么称呼它。他们会面的储藏室。她说，听着，那是最后一次了。我有一个未婚夫。我非常喜欢他。好了，珍娜，在《减肥1》和《2》中有很多删减片段，真的展示了安吉拉在
wanting to be excited for the wedding and also that Andy is driving her crazy. And then she runs to Dwight. It's sort of this love triangle. And the documentary crew clearly decided to ask her about it. And here was her response. It's in the deleted scenes. No, I'm not cheating on anybody. I have one fiancé and I have physical relations with one man. Hmm. She keeps it separate. One guy she'll marry and one guy for the shag.
想要为婚礼感到兴奋，但安迪又让她抓狂之间挣扎。然后她跑向德怀特。这算是一种三角恋。纪录片摄制组显然决定问她这件事。这是她的回应。在删减片段里。不，我没有背叛任何人。我有一个未婚夫，我和一个男人有身体关系。嗯。她把它们分开了。一个男人她会嫁给他，另一个男人用来寻欢作乐。
I guess Angela Martin is like, you know, once I'm at the aisle, it's done. Yeah. Once I speak my vows, I'll stop sleeping with Dwight. But for right now, I am engaged. This is a period of, I guess, non-commitment. But commitment, I don't know. I don't know. I don't know how she's going to deal with how bad shit crazy Andy makes her once they're married. What will her outlet be? But yes, I thought that was interesting because there's that moment when she comes out of the storage room with Dwight where she sees the camera. Right? And this talking head would have happened immediately after where they would have confronted her, which I thought was pretty balsy for the documentary crew. Well, they need to follow up on these things.
我想安吉拉·马丁是那种，你知道，一旦我走到红毯尽头，就结束了。是的。一旦我说了誓词，我就不会再和德怀特睡觉了。但现在，我订婚了。这是一个，我想，非承诺期。但承诺，我不知道。我不知道。我不知道当他们结婚后，安迪把她逼疯时，她会怎么处理。她的发泄口会是什么？但是的，我觉得这很有趣，因为当她和德怀特从储藏室出来看到摄像机时，有那一刻。对吧？这个采访镜头本应该紧随其后，他们会质问她，我觉得这对纪录片摄制组来说相当大胆。好吧，他们需要跟进这些事情。
Now we have a scene where Michael, through his window, sees that Pam is getting into her car, she's getting ready to drive to Pratt, and he has not said his goodbye. No, he hasn't. And I want you to know, I know whose office it was, that he was in. Was it Paul Lieberstein's? No, it was Jen Saladus. Okay. There you go. If you're curious, that's the writer's room that Michael was in.
现在我们有一个场景，迈克尔通过窗户看到帕姆正在上车，她准备开车去普拉特艺术学院，而他还没有跟她道别。不，他没有。我想让你知道，我知道他在谁的办公室里。是保罗·利伯斯坦的吗？不，是简·萨拉达斯的。好吧。就是这样。如果你好奇的话，那就是迈克尔所在的编剧室。
And poor Michael, he practically wipes out two flights of stairs trying to get to Pam so he could say goodbye. It's so funny. And he wrote her a poem, but he left it upstairs. It ends with the word seagulls. Here's what I have to say about this scene. Pam is going to drive to New York and a pencil skirt. Also, here was my question. Where is she going to park your car? There's nowhere to park your car in New York City. You have to pay for a parking spot. Well, she's going to Brooklyn. She's going to like a college campus. You think they have a spot for her? I think they do. Oh, okay. I think there's a campus parking lot.
可怜的迈克尔，他为了跟帕姆道别，差点在两层楼梯上摔倒。太搞笑了。他给她写了一首诗，但他把它落在楼上了。结尾是“海鸥”这个词。关于这个场景，我想说的是：帕姆要穿着铅笔裙开车去纽约。还有，我的问题是：她要把车停在哪里？纽约市根本没地方停车。你得付钱买停车位。好吧，她要去布鲁克林。她要去大学校园。你觉得他们有她的车位吗？我觉得有。哦，好吧。我觉得有个校园停车场。
Okay, okay, okay. I'm not worried about that. I'm worried about why did she come into work even for a half day? Why didn't she change her clothes? She's going to arrive at Pratt in a pencil skirt and panty hose. Really? Really? Pam.
好吧，好吧，好吧。我不担心那个。我担心的是她为什么还要来上班，哪怕是半天？她为什么不换衣服？她要穿着铅笔裙和连裤袜去普拉特艺术学院。真的吗？真的吗？帕姆。
I hope there's parking. Well, listen, I wanted you to know, Randy Cordray shared that this parking lot scene took place on an incredibly hot day. It was like triple-digit weather in Los Angeles. And, you know, Steve runs hot anyway. And he had to run into this scene. And it was super hot in a suit. Well, Phil Shea found a cooling vest that Steve could wear under his suit to help keep him cool. It's the type of vest that marathon runners and athletes have. They use it to cool their body temperature down. It has these little frozen gel packs. And Steve had that on under his suit. I've never heard of this. thing, which makes sense to me because I would never seek it out. I would never think how can I be
我希望有停车位。好吧，听着，我想让你知道，兰迪·科德雷分享说，这个停车场场景是在一个极其炎热的日子拍摄的。洛杉矶的气温达到了三位数。而且，你知道，史蒂夫本来就怕热。他不得不跑进这个场景。穿着西装超级热。好吧，菲尔·谢伊找到了一件冷却背心，史蒂夫可以穿在西装里面来帮助他降温。这是马拉松运动员和运动员穿的那种背心。他们用它来降低体温。它有这些小冷冻凝胶包。史蒂夫在西装下面穿了那个。我从来没听说过这个东西，这对我来说很有道理，因为我永远不会去寻找它。我永远不会想我怎么能在
colder in any situation. No, never. It's a whole thing. I googled it. There's many different types of cooling vests that you can get. Athletes use them. Soldiers use them. I mean, you know, it's like a whole thing. You know what I do own? What? A warming vest. I have a vest and you put little hot packs in it. And it keeps you warm. I bought it so that I could watch my son play ice hockey outdoors. Yeah. Well, we used to stuff those little hot pocket thingsies. What do you call them? Not the food hot pockets. What are they called? I love the idea of us having a vest filled with hot pockets, though. Because then if you get hungry, it's a snack as well. It keeps you warm and full. Listen, on the office, I had one skirt that had two little stitch pockets in the back,
任何情况下更冷。不，从来不会。这是一种专门的东西。我谷歌了一下。你可以买到很多不同类型的冷却背心。运动员用它们。士兵用它们。我的意思是，你知道，这是一种专门的东西。你知道我拥有什么吗？什么？一件保暖背心。我有一件背心，你可以把小暖宝宝放进去。它能让你保持温暖。我买它是为了看我儿子在户外打冰球。是的。好吧，我们过去常塞那些小暖宝宝。你叫它们什么？不是那种食物“热口袋”。它们叫什么？不过我喜欢我们穿着塞满热口袋的背心的想法。因为如果你饿了，它也是个零食。它让你既温暖又饱。听着，在《办公室》里，我有一条裙子，后面有两个小缝口袋，
and I had one little tiny stitch pocket in the front. They would give us those little hot pack things. Little hand warmers. Little hand warmers. I would stick two in my shoes. I would stick one in that front pocket, two in my back pocket. I'd stick a few in my bra. Same. Yeah, I remember that. Yeah. And if my sweater had pockets, I'd stick them in there. I'd stick so many of those on my body when we were filming outside when it was cold. One time our camera operator, Matt Stone, was like, Ann, just don't take this the wrong way. But I can see lumps in your butt on camera. Like they don't look human like human lumps. I was like, dang it. And I had to take my little heater. things out of my pockets. Well, I can't believe that they got a cooling vest, and I'm glad they did. I am, too. I thought that was so smart. Mm-hmm. Well, it's time for another weigh-in. Big announcement. They lost 31 pounds. Wow. Michael and Holly are so excited. They're going to do a wrap. It's the most adorable thing, because they're so dorky and cute together. Well, a little rap trivia is that they have
前面有一个小小的缝口袋。他们会给我们那些小暖宝宝。小暖手袋。小暖手袋。我会把两个塞进鞋子里。我会把一个塞进前口袋，两个塞进后口袋。我会往胸罩里塞几个。我也是。是的，我记得。是的。如果我的毛衣有口袋，我会把它们塞进去。当我们在外面拍摄，天气很冷的时候，我会往身上塞很多那种东西。有一次我们的摄像师马特·斯通说：“安，别误会。但我能在镜头里看到你屁股上的肿块。它们看起来不像人类的肿块。”我说：“该死。”我不得不把我的小加热器从口袋里拿出来。好吧，我不敢相信他们弄到了冷却背心，我很高兴他们这么做了。我也是。我觉得那太聪明了。嗯。好吧，又到了称重时间。大公告。他们减掉了31磅。哇。迈克尔和霍莉太兴奋了。他们要来一段说唱。这是最可爱的事情，因为他们在一起时太呆萌可爱了。好吧，关于说唱的一个小花絮是，他们有
about 10 minutes of them wrapping, even though the part that you see in the show was completely scripted, Even down to Holly, like, rubbing her jacket. Yeah, yeah, the wiki, wiki what? All of that was scripted. All of that was scripted. But they did go on and on. And Amy Ryan gave an interview where she said this was her favorite scene to shoot because they had so much fun. The crew said the same thing.
大约10分钟的说唱，尽管你在节目中看到的部分是完全写好的，甚至连霍莉摩擦她的夹克也是。是的，是的，那个“维基，维基什么”？所有这些都是写好的。所有这些都是写好的。但他们确实一直在说。艾米·瑞安在接受采访时说，这是她最喜欢拍的场景，因为他们玩得很开心。剧组也说了同样的话。
They said it was so much fun that those two just went off and that the chemistry was just so apparent. I think this was the scene when they were shooting when they realized, oh, yeah, these two, true love. Yeah. Well, now it's week three, and there is a new receptionist in town. Yes, Ronnie. Yeah, Ronnie played by Dale Raul. She has been in a ton of stuff. She was Maxine and True Blood.
他们说太有趣了，那两个人完全放飞自我，化学反应显而易见。我想这就是他们拍摄时意识到“哦，是的，这两个人，真爱”的场景。是的。好吧，现在是第三周，镇上来了一位新接待员。是的，罗尼。是的，由戴尔·劳尔饰演的罗尼。她演过很多东西。她是《真爱如血》里的玛克辛。
Oh, Maxine Fortinbury. I love True Blood. She was fantastic. Of course, you would know that. Yes. I have a crossover connection with Dale. Tell me. We were both on Fresh Off the Boat.
哦，玛克辛·福廷伯里。我喜欢《真爱如血》。她太棒了。当然，你会知道这一点。是的。我和戴尔有一个交叉联系。告诉我。我们都演过《初来乍到》。
Well, there you go. Not Monk, surprisingly, but fresh off the boat. Well, she will come back in season, This is not the last we're going to see of Ronnie. Meanwhile, we're going to see Pam in her first class. She looks so cute. She has like, I'm calling it the college ponytail. She wears this really cute ponytail at school.
好吧，就是这样。令人惊讶的不是《神探阿蒙》，而是《初来乍到》。好吧，她会在这一季回来，这不是我们最后一次见到罗尼。与此同时，我们要看到帕姆在她的第一堂课上。她看起来太可爱了。她扎着我称之为“大学马尾辫”的发型。她在学校里扎着这个非常可爱的马尾辫。
All right, the ponytail is the only thing that's cute about Pam. Are you kidding? I thought you looked so cute in all of your college scenes. Did you notice how young everyone else is in the class? Oh, you stop it. No, but this was a deliberate choice. Well, okay. Pam is in her little.
好吧，马尾辫是帕姆身上唯一可爱的地方。你在开玩笑吗？我觉得你在所有的大学场景里看起来都太可爱了。你注意到班里其他人有多年轻了吗？哦，你住口。不，但这是一种刻意的选择。好吧，好吧。帕姆在她的……
late 20s. Do you like how immediately I like stand up for my best friend. I'm like, you stop it. You are beautiful. You look just as young as those other ones. That's right. And you are smart. Thank you. You're welcome. I want you to know I was not being down on myself. I was just pointing out a deliberate production choice. Pam is in her late 20s and they made sure that everyone in this class that the background performers were all much younger. They're just starting off in college, right? Pam's going back to school. And they did want to create. this story for Pam that she is kind of, you know. Yeah.
二十多岁末期。你喜欢我立刻为我最好的朋友挺身而出吗？我说“你住口”。你很漂亮。你看上去和那些人一样年轻。没错。而且你很聪明。谢谢。不客气。我想让你知道我并没有看轻自己。我只是指出一个刻意的制作选择。帕姆二十多岁末期，他们确保班里的每个人，那些背景演员都年轻得多。他们刚开始上大学，对吧？帕姆是重返校园。他们确实想为帕姆创造这个故事，她有点，你知道。是的。
I don't know. What do they call it? A non-traditional student. There you go. Well, not only that, she's in the wrong class. The teacher who was played by Sandra Lowe, Professor Monaghan. She's got that zinger of a joke about Zaf Chancery, you know. Yeah.
我不知道。他们叫它什么？非传统学生。就是这样。不仅如此，她还走错了教室。由桑德拉·洛饰演的老师，莫纳汉教授。她讲了一个关于“Zaf Chancery”的冷笑话，你知道的。是的。
Which, by the way, I read a Reddit thread where people were like, that doesn't apply. It's wrong. Oh. Oh, my. Well, Pam does not end up leaving the class. And we got some mail. People are like, Pam has been so good about standing up for herself. Why doesn't she just leave the class? I don't know. I sympathized. I felt like she's new here. She feels out of place. She just got singled out. She's going to tuck her head down and know she'll do it right the next time. Yeah, but I guess it's going to mean she misses her actual first class. Back in the office, Holly hears this coughing. right? She's at her cubicle. Kelly is coughing. She sounds sick. Did you notice on Holly's desk what her nameplate says? Yes. Hollis. And then in quotes, Holly, P, flax. I did notice that. So that's her real name. Her name is Hollis.
顺便说一句，我读了一个Reddit帖子，人们说那不适用。那是错的。哦。天哪。好吧，帕姆最终没有离开教室。我们收到了一些邮件。人们说，帕姆在为自己挺身而出方面一直做得很好。为什么她不直接离开教室？我不知道。我很同情。我觉得她是新来的。她感到格格不入。她刚被单独挑出来。她会低下头，知道下次会做对的。是的，但我猜这意味着她错过了她真正的第一堂课。在办公室里，霍莉听到了咳嗽声，对吧？她在她的隔间里。凯利在咳嗽。她听起来病了。你注意到霍莉桌上的名牌写着什么了吗？是的。霍利斯。然后用引号写着“霍莉，P，弗拉克斯”。我注意到了。所以那是她的真名。她的名字叫霍利斯。
Hollis. Kelly has a talking head where she says she's on the third day of her cleansed diet where she's doing the lemon juice, maple syrup, and cayenne pepper and water. That's all she's allowed to have. have. Angela, have you ever done any of these fad diets? I haven't, but I had a roommate who did something with cayenne pepper and water, and I think it just gives you the runs, right? You just poop. You know, I got approached to do an ad for this diet tea that's supposed to flatten your tummy. So you drink the tea and it flattens your tummy. How? By making you poop a lot. Well, but it was like a cleansing tea. And I was like, well, first of all, I'm not going to do an ad for anything I don't believe in. So send me the tea and we'll see what happens. Did you drink the tea? I was doing splitting up together at the time and I was talking to Oliver Hudson about it and he said, I'll do it with you.
霍利斯。凯利有一个采访镜头，她说她正在进行为期三天的排毒饮食，只喝柠檬汁、枫糖浆、辣椒粉和水。那是她唯一被允许摄入的东西。安吉拉，你做过这些流行饮食吗？我没做过，但我有个室友做过辣椒粉和水之类的东西，我觉得那只会让你拉肚子，对吧？你只会排便。你知道，有人找我为一种据说能平坦小腹的减肥茶做广告。所以你喝这种茶，它就能平坦你的小腹。怎么做？通过让你大量排便。好吧，但这就像是一种排毒茶。我说，好吧，首先，我不会为任何我不相信的东西做广告。所以把茶寄给我，我们看看会发生什么。你喝了那茶吗？我当时正在拍《分分合合》，我和奥利弗·哈德森聊起这件事，他说，我和你一起做。
Let's both do the tea and see if we get flat tummies. He's so funny, but I can so hear him saying that because he's just like, let's do it. He was all in. So I asked for two packages of the tea. Oliver and I started doing it. Angela. Did you poop? First of all, I gained weight. What? Second of the second. of all, we're just pooping and farting and just, we're trying to work and do our scenes. Oh, no. The crew was like, stop drinking the tea, you guys. You're like, we're farting them out. They're like, seriously, we cannot have the two leads of our show drinking this tea. Being so flagellent on set. It's ruining everything. So I just, I don't know. I just don't do this stuff. Well, you know, my husband, he's super healthy and he just makes really good choices about what he
我们俩都喝这种茶，看看能不能有平坦的小腹。他太搞笑了，我完全能听到他这么说，因为他就是那种“我们做吧”的人。他全力以赴。所以我要了两包茶。奥利弗和我开始喝了。安吉拉。你排便了吗？首先，我增重了。什么？其次，我们只是在排便和放屁，我们试图工作和拍戏。哦，不。剧组说，你们别喝那茶了。你们就像是，我们在不停地排气。他们说，说真的，我们不能让节目的两位主演喝这种茶。在片场不停地排气。这毁了一切。所以我，我不知道。我只是不做这些事。好吧，你知道，我丈夫，他非常健康，他在饮食方面做出了非常好的选择
eats and he exercises. It's really annoying his ability to be so consistent. My hardest struggle is consistency, you know, just like making that space for myself. And I think it's even like when you peel back the layer, it's like making that time for yourself. And it's just a hard thing to do. Yeah. Well, I think we should take a break because I need a moment to center myself before Jan comes into the office. Oh, oh yes. And there's some really good Jan stuff I want to share. All right, we'll be right back. We are back, and so is Jan. Oh, yeah.
他锻炼身体。他能如此自律真的很烦人。我最难的挣扎是自律，你知道，就像为自己腾出空间。我觉得即使当你剥开这一层，就像是为你自己腾出时间。这是一件很难做到的事情。是的。好吧，我觉得我们应该休息一下，因为在简来到办公室之前，我需要一点时间来调整自己。哦，哦，是的。还有一些关于简的非常好的内容我想分享。好的，我们马上回来。我们回来了，简也回来了。哦，是的。
Jan enters the office and tells Ronnie to make her some copies of a document on Canary Yellow Paper. Oh, yeah, she walks in like she owns the place. She also does not acknowledge that she's speaking to a person she's never met. Oh, yeah, that's true. This made me wonder if Jan is entertaining Michael being in her life again so she can just use him and use the office. She's getting free copies, right? Yeah. Well, in the deleted scenes, there's a little bit of a...
简走进办公室，告诉罗尼用金丝雀黄色的纸给她复印一份文件。哦，是的，她走进来就像她是这里的主人一样。她也没有承认她是在和一个她从未见过的人说话。哦，是的，那是真的。这让我怀疑简是否在考虑让迈克尔重新回到她的生活中，这样她就可以利用他，利用这个办公室。她在免费复印，对吧？是的。好吧，在删减片段里，有一点关于这个的……
runner about this. She is giving Michael like a list of things she needs him to do. All her errands, go to the dry cleaner. She hands him a bag, like grocery shopping, etc. Like Michael is her personal assistant. And then when he kind of boxed at anything, she's like, well, I thought you wanted to help. Wow. So to me, I feel like Jan is using him. For sure. Jim has this talking head where he says Michael led us to believe he was the father of Jan's baby by telling us he was the father of Jan's baby. Well, this talking head would have continued. Oh. And they had to trim it. And Jim then holds up an email and says, but then Jan sent this email to everyone. And here's what Jan's email said. Hi, everyone. Jan here writing to share some wonderful news and to squash a rumor. First, the great
小插曲。她给了迈克尔一份她需要他做的事情清单。她所有的跑腿活，去干洗店。她递给他一个袋子，比如买杂货等等。就像迈克尔是她的私人助理。然后当他拒绝做任何事情时，她说，好吧，我还以为你想帮忙呢。哇。所以对我来说，我觉得简在利用他。肯定的。吉姆有一个采访镜头，他说迈克尔让我们相信他是简孩子的父亲，因为他告诉我们他是简孩子的父亲。好吧，这个采访镜头本应该继续。哦。他们不得不剪掉它。然后吉姆举起一封电子邮件说，但后来简给每个人发了这封邮件。这是简的邮件内容。大家好，我是简，写信来分享一些美妙的消息并平息谣言。首先，好消息是我怀孕了。我腹中美丽的女儿将在今年秋天准备好迎接世界，就在“Serenity by Jan”新系列发布前几个月。无耻的植入广告，我知道。别恨我。哈哈。总之，我也想澄清一下，孩子的父亲不是你们或我认识的任何人。记住，无论某人对我的孩子有多兴奋，这并不意味着他们就是父亲。最好的，简。附：希望很快能给你们寄点东西。太棒了。是的。所以她给办公室里的每个人都发了那封邮件。好吧，霍莉想知道简是谁。她说，迈克尔办公室里那个有脚的女人是谁？
news I am expecting. The beautiful baby girl inside me will be ready to meet the world this fall, just a few months before the launch of the new Serenity by Jane. Jan line. Shameless plug I know. Don't hate me. L.O.L. Anyway, I also wanted to clarify that the father is not anyone that you or I have ever met. Remember, no matter how excited, someone is about my baby, it does not make them the father. Best Jan. P.S. Hope to ship you something soon. That's amazing. Yeah. So she sent that email to everyone in the office. Well, Holly would like to know who is Jan. She says, who's that woman in Michael's office with the feet?
因为迈克尔在给简揉脚。奥斯卡解释说她是迈克尔的前女友。霍莉立刻决定，是的，你可以把我的号码给你的瑜伽老师。我想和你的热瑜伽老师约会。是的。他火辣的热瑜伽老师，因为他教热瑜伽，而且他很火辣。我相信他身体很柔软。是的。
Because Michael is rubbing Jan's feet. Oscar explains that she's Michael's ex-girlfriend. And Holly immediately decides, yes, you can give your yoga teacher my number. I want to date your hot yoga teacher. Yeah. His hot, hot yoga teacher, because he teaches hot yoga and he's hot. I'm sure he's very bendy. Yeah.
是的。然后霍莉无意中听到安吉拉责骂凯文是个白痴。霍莉要为凯文辩护，因为记住，德怀特告诉霍莉，凯文是作为特殊工作项目的一部分在那里。是的，当德怀特在欺负她的时候。是的。哦，她跑向安吉拉说，你怎么敢？你不能那样对他说话。这时每个人都意识到了，包括凯文，德怀特告诉了霍莉什么。安吉拉对这一刻感到非常高兴。嗯。她笑个不停。不，她喜欢霍莉被羞辱。嗯。
Yeah. Then Holly overhears Angela berating Kevin for being an idiot. And Holly is going to come to Kevin's defense because remember, Dwight told Holly that Kevin was there as part of a special work program. Yeah, when Dwight was hazing her. Yeah. Oh, she runs over to Angela and she's like, how dare you? You don't speak to him like that. And this is when everyone realizes, including Kevin, what Dwight told Holly. Angela is so delighted by this moment. Mm-hmm. She can't stop smiling. No, she loves that Holly has been humiliated. Mm-hmm.
可怜的凯文。他崩溃了。这意味着霍莉一直没有关注他，因为她想和他约会。不。他意识到了。好吧，现在安迪要在厨房里接近安吉拉。他在四个不同的婚礼地点支付了不可退还的定金。纳帕谷上空的热气球。嗯。世界著名的华特迪士尼艾普科特中心。
Poor Kevin. He's crushed. This means that Holly has not been paying attention to him because she wants to date him. No. He's realizing. Well, now Andy is going to approach Angela in the kitchen. He has made non-refundable deposits at four different wedding locations. Hot air balloons over Napa Valley. Mm-hmm. World famous Walt Disney's Epcot Center.
嗯。巴哈马群岛的潜水婚礼，以及威尔克斯-巴里万豪酒店的C宴会厅，对此她回答说：危险、俗气、鲨鱼、闹鬼。还有不。还有不。只是总的来说。还有不。当然，这意味着安吉拉和德怀特又要勾搭上了。我们有一个粉丝提问。凯拉想知道德怀特拍打安吉拉屁股时，那是写好的吗？因为
Mm-hmm. Scuba diving wedding in the Bahamas and the Wilkes Bar Marriott Ballroom C, to which she replies, dangerous, tacky, sharks, haunted. And no. And no. Just in general. And no. And of course, this means Angela and Dwight are going to hook up again. We had a fan question. Kayla would like to know when Dwight slaps Angela's butt was that scripted because
她觉得你的反应非常真实。你很惊讶。不，那是即兴表演。那是雷恩·威尔逊。但现在，听着，伙计们，雷恩和我是非常非常好的朋友。我们总是会拍几个镜头，尝试给对方一点惊喜。在我知道不会让任何人感到不舒服的范围内，反之亦然。
she thought your reaction was very genuine. You were surprised. No, that was improvised. That was Rain Wilson. But now, listen, you guys, Rain and I were very, very good friends. And we would always do a few takes where we would try to surprise each other a little bit. Within the boundaries of what I knew would not make anyone uncomfortable and vice versa.
对。所以，不，那是雷恩，只是即兴发挥。让我措手不及，这就是为什么我的反应如此真诚。我们还收到了爱丽丝的邮件，她想问，在随后的采访镜头中，那是即兴表演吗？因为那是我最喜欢的镜头之一。你知道吗？人们引用这个采访镜头给我听，它是完全写好的，读起来是这样的：我有一个舒适的被子和几个舒适的枕头。我通常读一章书，8点半就熄灯。这就是我晚上睡觉的方式。完全写好的。
Right. And so, no, that was Rain, just mixing it up. And catching me off guard, which is why my reaction is so earnest. We also got mail from Alice, who would like to ask, in your talking head afterwards, was any of that improvised because it's one of my all-time favorites? You know what? People quote this talking head to me, and it was completely scripted, and it read like this. I have a nice comforter and several cozy pillows. I usually read a chapter of a book, and it's lights out by 8.30. That's how I sleep at night. Completely scripted.
你8点半就睡觉。我知道。我有很多猫要照顾。它们起得很早。好吧，现在吉姆和帕姆要通过视频通话交谈。伙计们，旧技术警报，这可是件大事。这是一个真正的实时iChat。记得iChat吗？是的。是的。这是在Zoom之前。这是在FaceTime之前。而且，你知道，德怀特很恼火。迈克尔非常兴奋，拿起电脑想带帕姆到处看看。我知道，这让她有点恶心。她说，你能把我放下吗？我觉得这太可爱了。伙计们，这是实时发生的。我们收到了一些来自爱丽丝·R和布里安娜·P的问题。你们是怎么拍摄视频聊天场景的？好吧，那是直播。他们在仓库布景上搭建了一个小布景，看起来像我在普拉特的宿舍。我坐在那里，我们直播了这个。真的很可爱。是的。我必须说，我真的很兴奋，因为在这一集的拍摄过程中，我不在我们的片场。我真的在拍摄节目。我真的在拍摄外景来拍摄帕姆的艺术学校。所以在那一天，我只记得我有多兴奋。尽管我一直在仓库布景上，但我还是能过来吃热点心。我留下来吃了午饭。是的，这是我们作为闺蜜最难的事情之一，就是你在普拉特艺术学院的时候。是的。你不在我们的片场。你在外景地。所以我太兴奋了。你在那里。关于这一点，我想分享的一件事是兰迪在DVD评论中谈到的，那就是
You go to bed at 8.30. I know. I have lots of cats to take care of. They get up early. Well, now Jim and Pam are going to talk via video call. You guys, old tech alert, this was a real big deal. This was an actual live I-chat. Remember I-chat? Yeah. Yeah. This is before Zoom. This is before FaceTime. And, you know, Dwight is annoyed. Michael is so excited and picks up the computer and wants to show Pam all around. I know, which is making her a little sick. She's like, can you please put me down? I thought it was so cute. Guys, this happened in real time. We had some questions from Alice R and Brianna P. How'd you shoot the video chat scenes? Well, it was live. They built a little set over on the warehouse set to look like my dorm room at Pratt. And I sat there and we did this live. It was really cute. Yeah. And I have to say, I was really excited because during most of this episode, I was not on our set. I was really filming on the show. I was really filming on. location to film Pam's art school. And so for this day, I just remember how excited I was. Even though I was all the way on the warehouse set, I was able to come over for hot snack. I stayed for lunch. Yes, this was one of the hardest things for us as BFFs is when you were at the Pratt School of Art. Yep. You were not on our set. You were on location. So I was so excited. You were there. And one thing I want to share about this that Randy talked about in the DVD commentary is that
这个实时iChat，珍娜，导致了各种技术问题。我记得。是的，我记得，因为我们不得不开始和停止。事情是这样的。当史蒂夫拿起笔记本电脑带着你走动时，摄像机侧面的无线微波系统会被触发。是的。它会关闭摄像机，这意味着我们能稍微聚一下，因为他们必须解决这个问题。我只记得拍摄采访镜头，我觉得他们把电脑放在椅子上的方式太可爱了。
This live I chat, Jenna, caused all kinds of technical problems. I remember. Yeah, I remember because we had to start and stop. Here's what happened. The wireless microwave system on the side of the cameras would get triggered whenever Steve picked up the laptop and walked around with you. Yeah. It would shut the cameras off, which meant we got to hang out a little bit because they had to sort that out. I just remember shooting the talking head, and I thought it was so cute the way they put the computer on the chair.
我也这么觉得。好吧，现在大家又要称重了，猜猜怎么着？他们增重了五磅，然后凯利晕倒了。是的。我们进入广告。我们回来时带了一些真正的菲利斯式的刻薄。嗯。菲利斯对安吉拉非常自鸣得意，而且，你知道，她在筹划斯坦利的生日派对，她只是在给安吉拉下命令。她是。她想吃点蛋糕。嗯。每当安吉拉看起来好像要反对时，菲利斯只是给了一个眼神。就像，我们会这样做的。
I did too. Well, now the gang is going to weigh in again, and guess what? They've gained five pounds, and then Kelly passes out. Yeah. And we go to commercial. We come back with some real Phyllis sass. Mm-hmm. Phyllis is super smug with Angela, and, you know, she's planning Stanley's birthday party, and she's just giving Angela marching orders. She is. She would like to get some cake. Mm-hmm. And anytime Angela seems like she might disagree, Phyllis just kind of gives a little look. Like, we will be doing it this way.
这就是原因。是的。删减片段里有更多菲利斯的刻薄。她这一整集都在给安吉拉找麻烦。好吧，我们在《再见托比》的结尾讨论过这个。菲利斯抓到德怀特和安吉拉在办公室里做那事。我们想知道，这意味着什么？好吧，这让菲利斯飘飘然了。
And here's why. Yeah. And there was more Phyllis sass in the deleted scenes. She was given Angela grief this whole episode. Well, we talked about this at the end of Goodbye Toby. Phyllis catches Dwight and Angela getting it on in the office. And we wondered, what does this mean? Well, it has gone to Phyllis's head.
她有权力了。嗯。霍莉建议他们用水果代替蛋糕。迈克尔进来了，他要称重，他突然留了山羊胡，没有解释。是的。但他留了山羊胡。凯利·坎特利说那个山羊胡花了一个小时才贴上，所以他们必须把它计入当天的工作。他不是真的长出了山羊胡？
She has power. Mm-hmm. Holly suggests that they do fruit instead of cake. Michael comes in, he's going to weigh in, he suddenly has a goatee, no explanation. Yeah. But he has a goatee. Kelly Cantley said that goatee took an hour to put on, so they had to factor that into the day. He didn't just grow a goatee?
不。他们的山羊胡都不是真的。不。她就是这么说的。不。一个都不是？它们都是贴上去的。然后他们必须确保它们在整集中保持正确的形状和大小，以保持连贯性。
No. None of their goatees were real. No. That's what she said. No. None of them? They were all put on. And then they had to keep track that they were the right shape and size goate throughout the
而且凯利说在播出时，他们收到了一些邮件，说有几个山羊胡贴歪了。天哪。好吧，迈克尔要带着他的山羊胡去会议室，他要召开一个会议。是的。因为他想让每个人都知道什么是导致死亡的主要原因。是肥胖引起的疾病。他希望每个人都更认真地对待这件事，这样他们就不会死于肥胖。是的。吉姆承诺减掉65磅。他在讽刺。迈克尔没听出来。他很激动。他说如果每个人都减掉五磅，加上吉姆的65磅，我们就能赢了。好吧，安吉拉向安迪提交了她的婚礼标准清单。这相当具有挑战性。这是她必须拥有的东西
episode for continuity. And Kelly said at the time, this aired, they got some mail that a few of the goatees were off. Gosh. Well, Michael is going to take his goate into the conference room and he's going to call a meeting. Yeah. Because he wants everyone to know what is the leading cause of death. It is obesity-caused illness. He wants everyone to take this more seriously so they don't die of obesity. Yeah. Jim pledges to lose 65 pounds. He's being sarcastic. Michael doesn't get it. He's thrilled. He says if everybody loses five pounds, that in addition to Jim 65, we're going to win this thing. Well, Angela has presented Andy with her list of criteria for her wedding. It's pretty challenging. Here are the things she has to have
为了嫁给安迪。好的。美国大陆上一座有一千年历史的教堂。必须有彩虹，24小时待命的兽医。然后她传呼德怀特在楼下见她，因为她实在受不了和安迪在一起。但安迪告诉安吉拉，你知道吗？我不在乎我们在哪里结婚，因为我只在乎和你共度余生。这融化了安吉拉冰冷冰冷的心。确实。她没有去仓库赴德怀特的约。
in order to marry Andy. Okay. A thousand-year-old church in the continental United States. There has to be a rainbow, 24-hour veterinarian on call. And then she pages Dwight. to meet her downstairs because she just can't really stand being around Andy. But Andy tells Angela, you know what? I don't care where we get married because all I care about is spending the rest of my life with you. This melts Angela's cold, cold heart. It does. And she does not show up for her rendezvous with Dwight in the warehouse.
她给了安迪一个吻。当然他得发出点声音。他发出了像“呜”的声音。是的。好吧，有一个非常甜蜜的删减片段展示了安吉拉试图通过婚礼与安迪建立联系。它在休息室里，我给它起名叫“过度活跃的安吉拉”？嗯。
She gives Andy a little kiss. And of course he has to make a noise. He makes like a boo. Yeah. Well, there's a very sweet deleted scene that shows Angela. trying to bond with Andy over the wedding. It's in the break room, and I titled it overly animated, Angela? Hmm.
我们可以做一个像你猫形状的蛋糕。他们能做到吗？是的。为了你，我的爱人，我会找到这片土地上最好的蛋糕师。他会带给我，先生，Bakes-A-Lot，一个糖霜火腿森林。那做一个像，我不知道，猫砂盆形状的怎么样？嘿！对吧？我的意思是，它是恶心的还是美妙的？
We could get a cake shape like your cat. They can do that? Yeah. For you, my love, I will find the finest cake smith in all the land. And it didla bring me, sir, Bakes-A-Lot, a Frosting Ham Forest. What about one shape like, I don't know, a litter box? Hey-oh! Right? I mean, is it gross or wonderful?
啊，我不知道。我要回我的办公桌了。如果你需要我，传呼我。你是谁？我知道。啊，我不知道。这个人是谁？我不知道。
Ah, I don't know. I'll be at my desk. Page me if you need me. Who are you? I know. Ah, I don't know. Who is this person? I don't know.
哦，过度活跃的安吉拉。她在努力。也许他应该做些疯狂的填词游戏。你喜欢那些。我喜欢填词游戏，并继续建议做看起来像猫或猫配件的蛋糕。这是通往你心里的路。好吧，吉姆已经到达帕姆的宿舍了。
Oh, overly animated, Angela. She was trying. Maybe he should just do some madlibs. You love those. I love madlibs and keep suggesting cakes that look like cats or cat accessories. It's a way to your heart. Well, Jim has arrived at Pam's dorm room.
你注意到帕姆是宿舍管理员了吗？我注意到了。她是RA。太完美了。这很完美，但也像帕姆。承担一份工作。得了吧。好吧，吉姆告诉纪录片摄制组，你知道吗？
Did you notice that Pam is the resident advisor? I did. She's the RA. It's so perfect. It's perfect, but it's also like Pam. Take on a job. Come on. Well, Jim tells the documentary crew, you know what?
你为什么不去看看帕姆在那边的艺术作品？当他们转过身去看时，他迅速关上了门，对吧？嗯。在18分31秒，你听到摄影师叹气。你听到兰德尔·艾因霍恩叹气。是的，那是兰德尔。那是即兴表演。
Why did you go check out Pam's art over there? And when they turn to look for it, he quickly shuts the door, right? Mm-hmm. And at 18 minutes, 31 seconds, you hear the cameraman sigh. You hear Randall Einhorn sigh. Yes, that's Randall. And that was improvised.
他只是那样做了，他们很喜欢，就保留了下来。哦，是的。太有趣了。我想说，帕姆，谢谢你终于在艺术学校穿了连帽衫或任何休闲服装。我觉得她自从到那里以来就一直穿得太正式了。我们在这件事上意见不一致。我觉得帕姆在艺术学校看起来很棒。我喜欢她的马尾辫。
He just did that and they loved it and they kept it in. Oh, yeah. So fun. I would like to say, Pam, thank you for finally wearing a hoodie or any kind of casual clothing here at art school. I feel like she just has been overdressed since she got there. We are on two different pages on this. I think that Pam has looked amazing for art school. I love her ponytail.
我只是觉得，这是一个选择，我应该说，这一切都是一个选择。这是故意的。这一切都是为了让她稍微突出一点，就像她穿得不像今天年轻人穿的那样。对。好吧。所以，我在为这件事找她麻烦，但伙计们，我们计划好了。对。还有她那做作的说话方式，她怎么说“早上好，蒂莉”。
I just think, and this was a choice that, I should say that, this has all been a choice. It's on purpose. It's all to make her stand out a little bit, to be like she isn't dressing the way the young people dressed today. Right. Okay. So like, I'm giving her grief about it, but you guys, we planned this. Right. And also her affected speech, how she's like, top of the morning, Tilly.
我们要走到这边吗？也许我们会坐在这里。让我把腿交叉在丝袜里。你在说什么？她就是那样说话的。不，她没有。你在做什么？我只是在逗你。
Shall we walk over here? Perhaps we'll sit here. Let me cross my legs in my stockings. What are you talking about? That's how she talks. No, she does not. What are you doing? I'm just messing with you.
我们要走过去吗？也许我们坐在这儿。让我把穿着丝袜的双腿交叠起来。你在说什么呢？她就是那样说话的。不，她才没有。你在干什么？我只是在逗你玩。
I really got worried. I was like, what? I am messing with you. I don't know how long Jim and Pam got to hang out and smooch, but Pam got a knock on her door. There was some girl mad at another girl because someone took someone soy milk. And now Jim is in like the dorm room common area at 18 minutes 55 seconds. Yeah, he's watching a baseball game. Yes.
我真的很担心。我当时想，什么？我在跟你开玩笑呢。我不知道吉姆和帕姆能在一起待多久、亲热多久，但帕姆的门被敲响了。有个女孩因为别人拿了她的豆奶而对另一个女孩很生气。现在吉姆在18分55秒时出现在宿舍的公共区域。是的，他在看棒球比赛。没错。
And Jenna, you can very faintly hear some sort of. baseball commentators like announcers, sports announcers. Those were played by our very own producer, James O'Carry and Eric Colgin. All right. See, I wondered, is that a real baseball game? So it's obviously real baseball footage, but then we put our own commentators on it. That's right. So Jen and I have been in touch with James. He is fantastic. He was that guy that could like get you anything on set. If you needed it, James got it. And we had lots of questions for him. And he answered him for this episode. He even had the shooting draft. James, thank you so much. I feel like we might have a Jamesapedia. Yeah, it couldn't come at a better time. Yeah. You know, because we don't have
珍娜，你可以非常微弱地听到某种棒球评论员的声音，就像播音员、体育播音员一样。那些是由我们自己的制片人詹姆斯·奥卡里和埃里克·科尔金配音的。好吧。你看，我当时想，那是真的棒球比赛吗？所以这显然是真实的棒球录像，但我们加上了自己的评论员。没错。所以珍和我都和詹姆斯保持着联系。他太棒了。他就是那种在片场什么都能帮你搞定的人。如果你需要什么，詹姆斯都能弄到。我们有很多问题要问他。他为这一集回答了这些问题。他甚至还有拍摄剧本。詹姆斯，非常感谢你。我觉得我们可能需要一个“詹姆斯百科”。是的，这再合适不过了。是的。你知道，因为我们没有
Kentapedia anymore, James. James, Carrie, will you be our Jamesapedia? Should we talk about Stanley's birthday? I mean, it looks a little sad. Everyone's standing around eating fruit. Ronnie wants to know if anyone wants to dance. By the way, My Dolly Parton fans, did you catch the song playing? Oh, yeah. Here you come again. I love that song. I love that song, too.
“肯特百科”了，詹姆斯。詹姆斯·卡里，你愿意成为我们的“詹姆斯百科”吗？我们要聊聊斯坦利的生日吗？我的意思是，看起来有点悲伤。大家站在那儿吃水果。罗尼想知道有没有人想跳舞。顺便问一下，我的多莉·帕顿粉丝们，你们注意到播放的歌了吗？哦，是的。《Here You Come Again》。我喜欢那首歌。我也喜欢那首歌。
I went and listened to it after I watched the episode. It's not the song I would play at a birthday party. No. No. Probably not. But I love that song. People are going to sneak off from this party, and they're going to have some cake in the warehouse. The warehouse is the sneak site, clearly.
我看过这一集后去听了那首歌。这不是我会在生日派对上放的歌。不。不。可能不会。但我喜欢那首歌。人们会从这个派对溜走，然后去仓库里吃蛋糕。仓库显然是溜号的地方。
Clearly, and I mean, isn't Angela uncomfortable being in that room with all those other people, including her fiancé? She doesn't have any guilt about it. I guess not. She has no problem sleeping at night. We've established that. That's true. Stanley is in the room with the cake, but he's not even eating it. He said his tastes have changed.
显然，我的意思是，安吉拉和所有其他人（包括她的未婚夫）待在那个房间里不觉得不舒服吗？她对此没有任何愧疚感。我想没有。她晚上睡觉一点问题都没有。我们已经确定了这一点。那是真的。斯坦利在有蛋糕的房间里，但他甚至没吃。他说他的口味变了。
Now all he likes is baklava, which I thought was a really interesting thing to say because baklava is very, very, very sweet. Like if you've lost your sweet tooth, I mean, it's nutty. I love a baklava. I do too. It's dense, though. It's a dense sugary treat. I know. And I often eat too much of it and I get a stomachache because, you know, they give you a tiny piece and I'll eat like five of them because they're just so good.
现在他只喜欢果仁蜜饼，我觉得这是一个非常有趣的说法，因为果仁蜜饼非常、非常、非常甜。如果你已经失去了对甜食的喜爱，我的意思是，它有很多坚果。我喜欢果仁蜜饼。我也喜欢。不过它很扎实。这是一种扎实的含糖点心。我知道。我经常吃太多，然后胃疼，因为你知道，他们给你一小块，我会吃掉五块，因为它们太好吃了。
Well, that's what happens with you. You're always like, Angie, look how cute. It's so tiny. I know. And then you're like, Angie, I have a stomachache. I know. Dwight, Holly, Michael and Ronnie spy on the group. Dwight's like, they should not be in there.
嗯，你就是这样。你总是说，安吉，看多可爱。它太小了。我知道。然后你就说，安吉，我胃疼。我知道。德怀特、霍莉、迈克尔和罗尼监视着那群人。德怀特说，他们不应该待在那里。
You know why he's saying that. And Michael says, we should have our own party. Let's all go play mini golf. Ronnie and Michael and Dwight and Holly. That force him. Oh, I wish that happened. Me too. Well, Holly can't go because she has a date tonight.
你知道他为什么这么说。迈克尔说，我们应该举办我们自己的派对。我们去打迷你高尔夫吧。罗尼、迈克尔、德怀特和霍莉。那四个人。哦，我真希望那发生了。我也是。好吧，霍莉不能去，因为她今晚有约会。
And then Michael has the sweetest talking head. He's like, Holly doesn't need any luck. Everyone who meets her instantly loves her. Yeah. So cute. I want these two kids to get together. Angela, I have a question for you about the next scene, which is when Dwight busts in and he kicks over the cake. Yeah.
然后迈克尔有一个最甜蜜的采访镜头。他说，霍莉不需要任何运气。每个见到她的人都会立刻爱上她。是的。太可爱了。我希望这两个孩子能在一起。安吉拉，关于下一个场景我有个问题要问你，就是德怀特闯进来踢翻蛋糕的时候。是的。
I wasn't there. I'm at art school. What was it like to shoot that scene? Here's the thing. That room was like, I mean, Jenna, it was like six feet by six feet. It is really small. And we were all in there. They tried to put chairs in so that we could sit, but not everyone could sit, obviously. We were pretty crammed in. I remember I couldn't look at Phyllis or I would laugh. Whenever she had her exchange with Michael, she would kind of, you know, start to break a little. And then Rain kicked over that cake with such like force. Yeah. It went flying. We all got cake on us.
我当时不在那儿。我在艺术学校。拍摄那个场景是什么感觉？事情是这样的。那个房间，我的意思是，珍娜，它大概只有六英尺乘六英尺。它真的很小。我们都挤在里面。他们试图放进椅子让我们坐下，但显然不是每个人都能坐。我们挤得厉害。我记得我不能看菲利斯，否则我会笑场。每当她和迈克尔有对手戏时，她就会有点，你知道，开始有点破功。然后雷恩用力踢翻了那个蛋糕。是的。它飞了出去。我们身上都沾到了蛋糕。
And then they would have to clean it up. We couldn't do it very many times because we were like, rain, do you have to kick it that hard? So pretty much I just remember being crammed in and trying not to laugh. Well, I thought that scene looked like it was a lot of fun to shoot. And I know, don't ask Rain Will. and to kick something unless you really want it kicked. Yeah, unless you want it to go flying. Yeah, I don't think they anticipated that that much cake would travel because it was quite a
然后他们不得不清理干净。我们不能拍太多次，因为我们当时说，雷恩，你一定要踢得那么用力吗？所以基本上我只记得挤在一起，努力不笑出来。嗯，我觉得那个场景拍起来应该很有趣。而且我知道，除非你真的想让东西被踢飞，否则别让雷恩·威尔逊去踢什么东西。是的，除非你想让它飞出去。是的，我不认为他们预料到会有那么多蛋糕飞出来，因为那清理起来相当麻烦。
cleanup. Well, now it is week five of the weight loss competition. The Scrant Branch is not doing very well. Holly tells us that corporate has now upped the prize to five vacation days, but things are breaking down between people. I mean, Kevin's in the kitchen. He's making himself a peanut butter bagel. Creed and Kelly are glaring at him.
好吧，现在是减肥比赛的第五周。斯克兰顿分部表现不太好。霍莉告诉我们，公司现在把奖金提高到了五天假期，但人们之间的关系正在破裂。我的意思是，凯文在厨房里。他正在给自己做一个花生酱百吉饼。克里德和凯利正怒视着他。
Oh, there's a deleted scene where Meredith and Kelly and Holly are working on the dry erase board. Yeah. And Kelly goes, I'm doing a blood type diet. And Meredith goes, who gives a fuck? And Kelly goes, would you say whore? And Holly goes, I got it. Okay. Hey, hey, hey.
哦，有一个删减片段，梅雷迪思、凯利和霍莉在白板上工作。是的。凯利说，我正在进行血型饮食法。梅雷迪思说，谁他妈在乎啊？凯利说，你说什么，妓女？霍莉说，我明白了。好了，嘿，嘿，嘿。
Oh, my gosh. I mean, things are getting really intense. They're so intense that Kelly says in a talking head that she swallowed a tapeworm last night that Creed gave her from Mexico. Kelly, why would you swallow a worm, Creed gave you. I know. Creed says it wasn't a tapeworm. Angela, I'll have you know. I looked it up. Yeah. The tapeworm diet is a real thing. Oh, God. Really? Well, it's obviously illegal in the United States, and it's totally dangerous. Where are they doing it? I don't know, but I guess you can buy pills that have a tapeworm egg inside of it. Don't do this. No. I read on Healthline that it doesn't even work.
哦，天哪。我的意思是，事情变得非常紧张。它们太紧张了，以至于凯利在采访中说她昨晚吞下了一条克里德从墨西哥给她的绦虫。凯利，你为什么要吞下克里德给你的虫子？我知道。克里德说那不是绦虫。安吉拉，我得让你知道。我查过了。是的。绦虫减肥法是真实存在的。哦，天哪。真的吗？好吧，这在美国显然是非法的，而且非常危险。他们在哪里做这个？我不知道，但我猜你可以买到里面有绦虫卵的药丸。别这么做。不。我在Healthline上读到它根本没用。
Because yes, it feeds off your body's nutrients, but it feeds off the good stuff too, right? It doesn't just eat your fat, everybody. It eats everything. And you get really sick. You can get diarrhea, abdominal pain, nausea, fever, weakness. You can also get bacterial infections. You can get neurological issues. Most of these pills are a scam.
因为是的，它确实以你身体的营养为食，但它也吃好东西，对吧？大家，它不只是吃你的脂肪。它吃掉一切。你会病得很重。你会腹泻、腹痛、恶心、发烧、虚弱。你还会感染细菌。你可能会有神经系统问题。这些药丸大多是骗局。
Okay, they do not really have a tapeworm. But a woman in Iowa swallowed a real one and she got. super sick and she had to confess to her doctor what she did. He had to report it to the State Department. It was a whole crazy thing. He didn't even know how to kill it. It was a whole thing. Guys, do not swallow a tapeworm on purpose. Our words I'm saying, just in case anyone out there thought they should. You know, Jenna, I have a tapeworm story. But you know I'm going to save it for the finale. When we are done with the whole run of the office, Office, you will remember. I don't want to spoil it. There is a scene in the finale. I don't want to spoil it. You'll remember, Jenna. Rain and I traded tapeworm stories. I'm saving it for the finale. Guys, if you've ever had a reason to tune in to at least our finale episode of Office, ladies, you have it now. There is a real life Angela Rain moment that happens behind the scenes of the finale.
好吧，他们并没有真的有绦虫。但爱荷华州的一名妇女吞下了一条真的，她病得非常重，不得不向医生坦白她做了什么。他不得不向州政府报告。这整件事太疯狂了。他甚至不知道怎么杀死它。这真是一团糟。伙计们，千万不要故意吞下绦虫。这是我们的忠告，以防有人觉得他们应该这么做。你知道，珍娜，我有一个关于绦虫的故事。但你知道我会把它留到大结局再说。当我们完成《办公室》的全部剧集时，你会记得的。我不想剧透。大结局里有一个场景。我不想剧透。你会记得的，珍娜。雷恩和我交换过绦虫故事。我把它留到大结局。伙计们，如果你们曾经有理由收看我们《办公室》的大结局，女士们，你们现在有了。在大结局的幕后，有一个真实的安吉拉和雷恩的时刻。
it involves a tapeworm. We'll get to it. Well, guys, that's weight loss part one. We will be back next week with weight loss part two when Jim has a big surprise for Pam. We're going to tell you all about it. Aw, jam fans, you don't want to miss it. See you then.
它涉及一条绦虫。我们会讲到的。好吧，伙计们，这就是减肥比赛的第一部分。我们下周会带着减肥比赛的第二部分回来，届时吉姆会给帕姆一个大惊喜。我们会把一切都告诉你们。噢，吉姆和帕姆的粉丝们，你们不想错过它的。到时候见。
See you. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jirkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Molly Nugent. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。感谢收听《办公室女士》的第二杯。本集最初是与Earwolf合作制作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·吉尔金斯，我们的音频工程师和助理制片人是莫莉·纽金特。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。